We'll,
I've what's with the funky bag fellow?
Look at that beautiful hippie case
you got going on there. We've got the,
the Bandanna Rockin the pygmy has
returned. When did you become the big pig?
Me and not a the viking.
Yeah,
I think that was just something that
kind of naturally changed a couple of a
weeks ago. Oh, a couple of weeks ago.
Yeah. So uh, you've returned everybody.
Justin wren. Um, you were a, you're going
to be fighting for belter now. Yeah.
It's spelled throw the sucker right
up, right up to you. That absolutely.
It's Bella tore one 41. Uh,
and yeah, it's Friday night.
August 28th he'll be on spike.
So you talked about doing this when you
were here before and you said it was a
good way to raise awareness for
your cause. Fight for the forgotten.
You got the tee shirt on right now.
Is it fight for the forgotten.org?
Is that the uh,
fight for the forgotten.org right now
and a fight for the forgotten.com will be
changed in the matter of a day or two.
So you decided to make a comeback just
to try to raise awareness and help these
pygmies. That's the number one motivation
for sure. Second would be a man.
I love the sport. I love the sport.
Uh, just like you. But uh, yeah,
I think that's a great opportunity
to give my family a voice.
And how long has it been since you
fought? It's been five years, bro. Wow.
Five years. Two months. How
old are you now? I'm 28.
He's still a young and damn good. Still
got at least seven years. Yeah. Oh,
for sure. Especially
heavyweights. Heavyweights. A,
I watched some videos
of you training to man,
you're looking good dude for five years
off. That's crazy. Yeah. I guess, uh,
in the forest it wasn't too, too much of
a fatty diet at like here in the states.
Well, it's not just that, I'm like, you
didn't take any beatings. You didn't,
you know, no gym wars, you know, a
stress on your joints. All that. The,
I got to heal up a lot on the,
the battle wound kind of things.
I mean I went through a lot of sickness
and stuff. But besides that, like yeah,
fighting wise I healed up
from a lot of injuries.
Imagine if like you have a malaria
actually gives you endurance or something
crazy. That'd be awesome. I
go now and again, you know,
cause they say they like certain things
are actually good for injuries like bee
stings, like are good for arthritis. Some
strange went. Yeah. Yeah. Like they uh,
they put beast things on people that
have certain types of arthritis and it
actually helps relieve them.
Well imagine if people found out that
I'm like malaria. Cause you were,
you were saying you were like basically
yeah, that was about the day for sure.
Um, it would, one thing that's
crazy say insect bites, um,
there's a way that they do sutures or
stitches in the Congo with these crazy
ants and a,
they're these army ants or soldier ants
that literally the pierce your skin.
And so they'll just take
it and let it bite a wound.
Cause then they pull the body off and so
they leave the head leave the mandibles
or the jaw that literally close your
wound that way I've been bit by Amanda.
They're terrible.
That's fucking crazy.
So you just walk around with a bunch
of heads on a cut. Right? Absolutely.
It does work. It works. It works
for sure. Yeah. It's like a staple.
Yeah. It'd be just like getting
staples, I guess necessity.
The mother of invention, uh, I don't know
if you know this, but this is a crazy,
a malaria fact.
He could throw around malaria has killed
half of the people that have ever died
ever in the world. Wow.
That's crazy. That's nuts.
Had no idea. Um, but
I believe it cause uh,
absolutely believe it cause
it's terrible. It's um, I,
I've known people that will get
ahead of it. Be that picture. Yeah.
There you go bro. Fuck, I
told us that is nuts. Wow.
Those guys have some really long,
we're looking at a photo of the army
ants being used to suture or wound.
And those, those ones have these
crazy long and slender ones,
but the ones in Congo, they
have these thick just nuts.
So yeah, look right there.
We'll do that one up top.
That's crazy. That one might be,
is that fair shot?
That looks fake as fuck.
But that's just stitches. Yeah,
that's a well necessity, right?
I mean you got to figure out
a way to close things up.
There's no crazy glue in the
Congo, right? No, no. Uh, they,
they use other kinds of stuff that's
real sticky SAP to kind of, uh,
men things together. Um, from trees.
They also use vines to tie up a
bunch of stuff like soccer balls.
They'll use the tee shirt, old tee shirt
or rag, and then they just use, uh,
these vines in time so tightly.
It's becomes a perfectly round ball,
not perfectly round, but round
enough to kick around. Well,
that's one of the things about soccer
that people find appealing is that it's
not that hard to create a ball. And all
you need is just flat ground. Right.
Know it's why it's such a good sport
for people that don't have money. Yeah.
They even play with half,
half a flattened balls that,
that the kicker around cause
they still use it. So yeah,
everybody's using the same ball.
I guess it's not as good,
but they get beaten up and popped and
everything cause he sold it really cheap
soccer balls anyways. They're only
going to last a couple of weeks.
But now when you say the Congo,
the Congo itself is really huge.
Right?
I mean I think if I'm not mistaken,
I think it's as wide as the
United States of America.
I think it might be like three quarters
of the continental United States,
something like that. It's the 10th
largest country in the world, I believe.
And so it's, it's massive. It's only
got about 74 million people. Um,
but I think 85% of those
people or maybe 80,
85% live on less than a dollar
a day. Um, it's a, yeah,
it's the flip flops between the poorest
country in the world and second poorest.
But it is the most underdeveloped
country. So Lisa, amount of roads,
clean water, uh, education, uh, medical,
like it's just the most underdeveloped.
Like when I go to Uganda,
I kind of get the feeling of whenever
I come back from Africa to the United
States and how it's just like, wow, this
is really developed compared to there.
When I go from Congo to
Uganda, I feel like, wow,
you gone has really developed and got
Three d movies, a yogurt land. Um,
they have a KFC actually I have
like four or five KFC KFCS now. Wow.
But they're racist north
and then they have a thing that gets
there. KFC. Yeah. But there it's a,
what's next? Watermelons.
Assholes. They are, they,
they have, what is it? Oh,
it's kind of fine dining at,
they have a weeder Breely stuff.
Yeah. It's real nice. It's a,
you got a charging station for your,
your smartphone and you to really, yeah.
Wow.
Kfcs Pretty God damn delicious.
I know it's supposedly not good for
you, but I'll tell you what, man,
I indulge and KFC,
every couple of months I'll buy some KFC
and I wait till I either eat it or I'll
wait till it gets cold and
I eat it with hot sauce.
KFC with some Habanero hot sauce,
get some LEU Kotecha to real Mexican
shit that you got to go to those funky
grocery stores to buy or online
some good stuff. Oh Dude,
it's just not good for you.
Apparently we were talking
about how they're putting
a sucralose and Diet Pepsi.
Do you need to figure out a way to make
Kentucky Fried checking? Good for you?
Yeah, that'd be great. That's, that's,
that's the worst thing about all
the tasty food is it's bad for you.
Exactly the opposite.
Fuck man.
What's up with that first world problems
like literally if anybody could talk
about first world problems,
it's you.
I mean a guy who goes from being a reality
star on the ultimate fighter fighting
in the UFC and then all of a sudden
you're living in the Congo. For,
for folks who don't know Justin's story,
Justin's been on the podcast a couple of
times and the story is, it's compelling.
It's crazy, it's heartwarming. It's just,
it's an amazing tale of a guy,
you who goes to the Congo and falls in
love with these people that don't have a
voice and, and, and you've
done incredible things.
And because of the money that was raised,
because your shows on here,
there's the fight for the
forgotten website a year.
How many wells have you created
now? Oh, we just celebrated, uh,
as of yesterday, our 25th
waterwall. So 25. Yeah. And,
and what's so great about
that to me is we were,
I was there for the first 13
water wells and now we've built,
so what I love and that website that was
up was we're partnered with water for
now it's water, ford.org
the number four. But, um,
it's kind of like we
set up an exit strategy,
not if this is a lifelong goal for me
and I'll be going back wholeheartedly
everything else.
But we,
our goal is to empower the locals
to be able to do it themselves.
And so I was there for the
first 13 water wells, add, um,
people from the director of implementation
of water for coming in and teaching
our guys hydrology,
geology,
all the different ins and outs of how
to drill a well and protect it. And um,
all the sanitation,
but we're investing in the local so
that they can be the answer to their own
problem, if that makes sense in that way.
Um, now we have 17 full time employees.
Wow. Yeah. And uh, we have two well
drilling teams, there's 14 guys on that.
And then when they go
out into the community,
we invite the community into the project.
We want them to feel a part of it.
Um,
there's a lot of organizations
out there and I'm not trying
to talk bad about them,
but they'll go in with $1 million
drilling rig and westerners that are,
you know, water engineers
and that's great. Um,
but they'll go into a community and
kind of say, you know, get back, uh,
we're here to do this for you because
you can't do it for yourself. Um,
and then the parts are so expensive,
they're not going to be able to repair it.
And when it breaks and
there's a good chance,
like I think two and three
of those expensive ones,
or at least no one third of them don't
operate after a year of drilling it.
And so what we want to do is go in there,
teach the locals how to do it themselves,
create a local economy for it and like
stimulate that, give people jobs. Um,
and then, and then let the
community fill a part of it.
So we look for day laborers in the
communities we go to and give them a job
while we're there and vitamin on the
process, teach them some of that. We've,
we've acquired some of those
guys that are just big,
strong love helping people now
they're part of our team. Um,
but the core of our team graduated
from university in degrees of community
development.
So that's what we want to do.
We want to go in there and
power the locals and yeah,
I'm a, I'm a big part of it.
And, but what I want to do is be
able to fan the flames and say,
you can do it because a
lot of international aid
tells the locals that they
can't do it for themselves. Um,
maybe, maybe they don't say that,
but it's kind of the way they go about
attacking the problem and you got to go
about it in a way that,
that kind of creates dignity for the
locals instead of kind of robs them of
dignity where they feel like
they can't help themselves.
That's a great way of approaching it. I'm
really, I'm so happy you're doing that.
I love that.
I love that you're trying to help these
people become a part of this solution,
you know, instead of like someone's
solving it for them. Now when you, um,
when you're involved in digging these
wells and you're saying these expensive,
uh, wells break or the machines, like
the pumps, how many parts are involved?
Is it like this is like a lot of stuff
as a different ways to do it. It's a lot.
It depends on how deep it is. Yeah. There,
there are multiple ways
of drilling a well.
The way we go about it is I
would say more simple but harder,
a lot harder, labor intensive. Um,
but it's house just to safe. Um,
well we for instance like the,
the deep wells,
those are great and honestly like in a
place like Ethiopia or places where it's
a, the water tables are super
deep. You're going to need those.
So those are absolutely part of the
solution. We need those water engineers.
We need those people doing that.
But whenever, say in the Congo,
it's a place that is a dangerous,
there's lots of rebel groups. Um,
lots of instability.
Uh,
they're not going to drive a million
dollar or half a million dollar drilling
rig deep into the forest over these
bridges that are notorious for collapsing
and taken and washing away.
A big lorries are 18 wheelers,
so they're not going to
drive them across there.
They can't get on the roads that we go
on because they're heavy, they're dense.
The parts break on the travel
just out to the villages.
And then once you get there, like going
into the pygmy villages where we are,
sometimes it takes,
it's taken up to two days I think to get
our equipment into the village after we
traveled there because we have to hike
it all in and we can hike an hour off the
nearest road to the village.
We can hike three hours from
the nearest road to the village.
And so we're hiking in over a ton of, so
when I'm saying this is hard, like our,
our guys are,
I think they're just as much fighters are
more than I am because they're written
down, they're hauling this
stuff in. Um, from the augers,
the way we do it is we use a tripod and
we use augers and ropes and pulleys and,
um, and we use these chisels that
go down and they're single pronged,
triple pronged.
And so we have all these tools we can
use for each obstacle that we're going to
hit as we go down in different geological
layers. This is incredible. So you're,
you're walking three hours
with a ton of equipment,
like a anywhere from gravel to bags of
cement that are a hundred pounds to the
rock breaker that can be 40 pounds and
other one that's 80 pounds and another
one that's like 130 pounds.
She's Christ. Uh, yeah.
And we're taking in all the PVC pipes
and a, the galvanized pipes and uh, uh,
yeah,
everything that a,
you can think of sand bricks and
we have to hike all that in from,
from the road side,
um,
to the village so it can take two days
of going back and forth to the truck if
we're walking that long
with all the supplies,
two to three days of just walking
with giant augers and steel pipes and
sandbags. And normally
it's like a day we, we,
we get there and we take all our stuff.
But yeah,
it's taken a long time
before because, uh, yeah,
it's a fight to even get there to start
the work. And then once we dig, man,
that's the biggest fight.
Yeah.
You must be exhausted by the time
you even get there. Absolutely.
Hiking with all this weight. Yeah. Wow.
And then in the ones we start
drilling our average well, um,
in other parts of the world where
the obstacles aren't as as big, um,
they can bust out a well in a
week, 10 days. But where we are,
we average 10 to 16 days per water.
Well,
and so our guys are out there and
living with the pygmies, that's,
that's something that we selected
every member of our team, um,
based on can they survive in the
forest? And more than that, can they,
can they love,
um,
my pygmy family because that's important
because other people around there,
a lot of them don't love them,
hate them or discriminate.
And so we want to find people that
are passionate about the people,
passionate about the water crisis
and then that way, um, yeah,
we can then teach them and put the
tools in their hands and invest in them.
And so that's what the last
four years has been for me.
Really investing in good people,
people that believe in it.
And then from there we can
a fanned the flames form.
Is it perplexing for you to have
discovered this place and you know,
to being alive in the 21st century with
all the modern communication and all
that and to,
to know that these people are out there
and no one has tried to do this before
and that you're,
you're stumbling across these giant
groups of people that don't have anyone
looking out for them. Is
that, yeah, it's nuts. I mean,
I would say that I'm not the only
guy that's ever tried to help him,
but I would say that,
um,
maybe we're trying to take an approach
and that's what's so awesome about the
university that I'm partnered with.
They've been working with the
pygmies for years and years. Um,
the guy that's leading the way, the dean
of the school committee development,
he's been doing it since
the year I was born. Um,
and then he started with the university
there for the last 10 years. Um,
so I went to them to say like,
hey,
how can we do this in a strategic way
that the impact will last that will keep
going on and on and on
instead of a, uh, a lot of,
I don't know if it's American culture or
what, but it's so fast, you know, and, uh,
we want the quick fix, the quick fix a
lot of times isn't the best route. Um,
that the, the results can just be
a temporary one where we have a,
I call it the show up, blow up and
blow out technique. We show up,
we do the show, we take the pictures and
then we leave and we never come back.
And so what we want to do is be opposite.
We want to build relationships,
get in touch. We want to be like a family
with them and then show them that, hey,
we're not just here for, for land. Um,
it because that's what we started
with first. We got them 2000,
470 acres of land that's 10
square kilometers in the forest.
Then we did the water and
now we're doing forgot them.
Meaning you purchased it for them
or how to purchase for them. Right.
We petitioned, lobbied,
uh, and basically said,
um, that we went to battle
scene. I mean a peaceful way,
but said these people are the first
people of Congo. Not just that.
A lot of people say that
the first people of Africa,
they're one of the oldest people groups
are so peaceful there. So if that's true,
then they're like,
that's the origins of humanity.
And I was just reading as Bill Nye thing
about, um, about humans. It was just, uh,
it was some quote that he had said
about the human race and then like,
it's been proven now that we are literally
all one race and the only thing is
degrading.
Our exposure to ultraviolet light and
different environments have changed the
way we look and how our bodies react to
the environment. But if that's the case,
I didn't know that.
But I love that stat and her fact,
well we know that all people, as
far as we know today, you know,
the knowledge kind of grows
and changes over the years.
But we know today that all human beings,
as far as we know, came from Africa.
So if that's the case,
these people you're dealing with could
very well be the oldest humans in the
world. And it kind of makes sense if you
really think about it, you know, I mean,
that's where the primates evolved and
came down from the trees and started
experimenting and moving along and trying
different environments and spreading
out throughout the land. It's
pretty nuts. Yeah. You're like,
get the cradle of life. It's
really a bizarre place. Yeah. Why?
All I know is man, it's the
culture. Their, their, their hearts.
They're such sweet people and I
don't use that word a whole lot,
but they're just, they're
sweet as can be. And um,
and so whenever we went
in, um, with, with my team,
basically it was like local lead. Um, I
mean I was, I was in the, in the picture,
but kind of playing behind the scenes
when it came to the negotiating. Um,
and they went in there and it was
the dean of the School of community
development.
It was my guy that's a,
the director of fight for
the forgotten and Congo.
And they said these are
the first people of Congo.
Why is it that they have
zero land of their own?
Because shouldn't they have some
land to call their own? And,
and we know that looking through
history and whether it was,
whether it was you or whether
it was your grandfather,
we stole this land from him.
We stole it.
They have none of their own and don't
they have a right to have some land.
And so that's kind of where, um, yeah,
we just lobbied on their
behalf and then said,
so if I bought the land in
fight for the forgotten,
if we would've bought it in our name,
we would have gotten a five
year certificate and we
would've had to renew things
and fees and everything every five years.
If we bought it in the name of the
university there that we partner with,
it would have been a 25 year certificate,
but then at the end of the 25 years,
we'd have to pay the same price that we
purchased it for 25 years earlier would
have been hundreds of thousands of dollars
every 25 years, maybe more. And um,
then we were thinking it's Kinda cool.
Um,
so in Africa I would say
a lot of the countries,
at least my understanding
is that, uh, it was,
it was the colonialist or colonist or
however you say that they were the ones
that set up the boundaries of the
countries. It wasn't the tribes.
And so like say Rwanda,
the Hutu and Tutsi,
they probably wouldn't have put their
country together right there because
they've had a long history
of disputes with each other.
So they wouldn't be in the same country.
They would have been to different
countries. Same thing in Congo,
there's over 200 tribes. So, um,
and Congo, what, what's very,
I dunno here where all America, America
pride and, or Texas and things like that.
But in Congo it's about
what tribe you're from.
And so in a lot of parts of Africa,
they're really proud about their tribe.
And so on the government level,
the strongest thing in court was buying
the land in the name of a tribe because
that's what they respect,
that's what they value.
And yet nobody was petition petitioning
and lobbying on behalf of the big nice.
So that's what we wanted to do.
We wanted to go in and say
these people deserve some land.
And we did was buy it from the people
that originally stole it from him,
whether it was dumb or their grandfather.
And so that benefited the people that were
basically oppressing them financially.
And we gave him years and years
worth of salary, um, to work with us.
And then on both sides we said,
um,
so they benefited financially
and the pygmies benefited
by having their own land.
You can't give them a water well without
them owning the land that they're on.
And so then we said, how can we give you
both water? That's what the next step is.
And the next step after that is food.
How can we start a farming project,
teach the pygmies how to farm correctly
or farm really for the first time. Um,
a lot of them worked for their former
masters and stuff like that, but then, um,
with the Mokpala, which means
non-Pygmies, um, we're like,
how can we teach you
better farming practices?
How can we need to
plant your seeds deeper?
You need to put your seeds farther apart
because they're not producing fruit
because,
or the corn is only half of the cob
instead of a full cob because your plants
are basically choking themselves out.
So we have three agriculturalist
were interning right now.
They've already done a great job,
but we're wanting to expand and
from three villages to 10 villages,
it's just an immense
sacrifice that you've,
you've done that you've taken on and it's,
it's probably quite difficult to find
people that have the same kind of passion
for it that you have. Does it, does he,
do you find that to be the case or your
passion has got to be infectious? I mean,
a lot of people I'm sure are,
uh, like I have been moved by it,
so thank you. But it's gotta be hard to
get people to go to the Congo though,
Dude. Yeah. Well that's, that's, that's
the reason we invest in the locals.
They're there, they're there in
Congo and they, they want, I mean,
the people we selected to solve
the water crisis, I mean they,
they know what it's like
to go without clean water.
So they can be the answer to that.
They're going to be the ones even more
passionate about it than me. Also,
it's the old adage, teach
a man to fish, right.
And you know a fish for like give a man
a fish and he's just one fish. That's it.
If you're teaching these people. Now
what? W W we got back to the, uh,
we got off the subject of the wells,
like, yes, the tripod and the Auger.
So what kind of a machine is
involved in digging this thing?
Yeah, it's, it's been developed by
water four and they're awesome. Uh,
an actual machine that,
that is small enough that we
can carry it into the villages.
How much does it weigh
that, uh, don't, don't know.
Maybe I shouldn't quote myself on
this, but I think it's around 150, 150,
200. So you guys have so carry that
peak hours. You could, uh, some,
some of the land is only like a 30
minute hike off the nearest quote unquote
road. That's just dirt and clay
and silt and big boulders. Uh,
but uh, yeah, most of them are 30
minutes an hour, two hours. One,
one's even three hours off
the nearest road. So yeah,
we got to hike that stuff all in.
Wow.
But I would say that the
manual drilling method,
which has been approved by
UNICEF and USAID and, um,
all these other major organizations that
say it can, it can be just as clean,
just as safe as the deep water wells,
as long as we do it to a high standard
and keep a high integrity when we do it.
Um, which means we backfill
it with a clay sanitary seal.
We'd put a cement plug on there so that
way there's no sort of a bacteria or
anything else I can get down into our,
well, we got to protect the water table.
And so we do that every single time
to a high standard. Um, but yeah,
so whenever we're doing it, the machine
is us, the manual drilling method,
we have wrenches and those augers.
And so those augers would look like kind
of like a full gallon ice auger. Uh,
yeah, very similar. It would be, um,
almost like a coffee can with
two claws on the bottom of it.
And at the top it's got a, uh, a stem
that attaches to a drilling stem.
And then at the top, I mean, whenever
you're starting from the first, uh,
down the first two or three feet,
like you can see the Auger and you just,
it was totally by, it's
almost like toasting. Yeah.
You just twist almost like a pump
for the forum. Oh yeah, man. Dude,
my forearms and my bike.
Well my right bicep over here and
my left tricep over here from it.
You got to switch it up dude.
I know we need to,
we need to have the augers changing, but
as of now it's just the same way. Um,
but yeah, so it's, it's us
just drilling and we can go,
we can go up to 150 feet
deep in the ground. And so
when we're doing that, it's,
it's crazy. Brewed. I think the
deepest we've gotten is like 70.
So when you're doing 70 feet,
what kind of ups the high 70 is,
do you have to keep attaching a longer
and longer pipe? Six foot, uh, or sorry,
six meter, 20 foot long segments, segments
of, of this drilling stem. That's a,
it's a square tube that's really
thick, really strong, really heavy. Um,
and then we just, we attach that at
the bottom. We have a rope that's,
that's secured to it so we can crank it
up. Um, so we crank it up on the way up.
Um, but, but we, we drill down.
So you're doing it all by hand.
You get to a certain depth rather,
and then you put another segment on and
then you start out, start from scratch.
Right. We attached the segments
the deeper we go. So once we're uh,
20 feet deep,
we got to attach another drilling
stem and the ones who were 40 foot,
we have to drilling stems once we're
60 foot, we have three drilling stones.
And how do you know where to drill?
Do you have one of those dudes
with one of them? Wishbones yeah.
Walking around to actually no, no. I was
wondering if that defining stuff is real.
I have, I have no clue. I hear, I
hear some people say it's legit,
but I haven't ever seen an action.
Hate that expression. Yeah, I hear Ya.
I hear Ya know, I have no clue.
To be honest to the validity.
I still know how it could possibly
really work. I have a friend who, uh,
had a well dug out here.
They hired,
this guy said to come over and they had
the two sticks and they just standing
there and like he's telling them where to
dig. That's not how we go about it. We,
we,
we have a B s machine,
which is basically,
um,
we hook up a car battery and some of
these other like electronic devices and
throw it in the ground. And
um, and then it kind of,
you have a laptop out there and, and
it shows us all this on a graph. Um,
but the way I did it
for the first 13 wells,
now our team's been
trained in that as well.
So that's what's so cool about us
partnering with water four is they're
continually training our guys
on the better drilling methods.
But whenever I was out there,
hey, we're in the rain forest,
there's got to be water, you
know, underneath our feet.
So let's, let's dig. And,
uh,
it was real tough the first time cause
we had eight failures over and over and
over because we were hitting sand stone.
Now with the V s machine,
we can see if it's sandstone, if
it's courts, if it's granted what,
what kind of rock is underneath
where the water table is.
We know how deep we need to drill.
Um,
but at first for the first 13 wells, we
were just trial and error. We dig. And if,
uh,
we even had one spot where we drilled
for 10 or 12 days and we hit water,
but then all of a sudden we hit
a layer of courts underneath it.
And so there was just about,
uh,
six feet of clean water on top of this,
courts. I was deep, but
we needed, we needed more.
We needed to break through that courts
and then be able to have hopefully what
would, what would be right
underneath that is a rushing, uh,
awesome aquifer for us to tap into that
would make that well sustainable a lot
longer. Um, but we couldn't
break through it at that time.
We just didn't have the right
tools. Now we do, but um,
but we just had to pick up and move.
So we picked up,
moved to maybe a football field away and
we went down the hill a little bit and
said, hopefully we don't hit
the courts a layer and yeah,
just a football field away. The geology
was different. Um, the, the water,
the recharge rate was great. Uh, the
water kept coming into our well. Um,
and then we have to do a
lot of different things.
Like we have to plunge and
bail and, uh, develop, uh,
the welds where it'll be clean. Uh,
we put a gravel pack around it. Um,
all this different stuff to make sure
the gravel pack acts as a filters and how
it works. I kind of in what it does is
it keeps, um, so we, we put down a PVC,
uh, like four inch, um, uh,
sorry. It's, it's um,
but w we put the pipe down there and
the gravel pack goes around it and the
gravel pack kind of keeps
any dirt, silt, sand, um,
depending on what layer we were in.
It keeps that from coming into our wells.
So that way the water that is inside
of our, of our casing, there we go.
Our four inch casing pipe, uh, that, that
allows, it has like little slits in it.
Maybe it would be like the size of a,
um,
a saw if you just kind of put us on there.
And it's every like centimeter apart
from each other and that we inside of our
casing and before the water touches
our pipe, like it's crystal clear,
it's clean. We tested all that stuff.
And so the gravel pack keeps the sand,
the dirt, the silt, anything
out of our well. Wow. Yeah.
That's incredible, man. It's
just incredible the amount of,
of thinking and planning and all that
it's involved in just getting people what
everybody here is just totally
takes for granted water. Yeah.
It's taken us a month in one spot a month
because we had a failed well and man,
it's brutal. And sometimes, uh, uh, man,
I'm thankful that I was a fighter because
sometimes you have to bite down on
your mouthpiece, just keep swinging. Um,
whenever you want to give up and you
have a team out there that's tired. Um,
so in between the failed well and
the other one we took two days off,
but we can't go back to,
we call it Bunia, um,
the town where we can kind of rest and
get some good food and come back out.
What we did was go to a little market and
get more dried fish and some more rice.
It's more beans. And we're
like, hey, we're out here.
We're not stopping until he,
until we finished two.
We get these people clean water.
And when you look at what
they're drinking wheat,
we do the water walks with them.
I love telling my team like,
let's do the walk that they have
to go on to get water. And I mean,
I've gone 45 minutes an hour walking
with a women because it's the women that
collect the water in that culture because
the men are often in the fields or
they're off hunting or they're
off doing stuff. So, um,
the women go and get the water and
it can be a 45 minute hour hike, um,
with these 20 liter Jerry
cans and a 20 liters,
I think full is like 40 or
44 pounds whenever it's full.
And they're going to get dirty water,
dirty water,
that is a 45 minute hike away from him
and they're bringing back one or two of
those 44 pound Jerry cans.
So some of these more boutique pygmy
women are literally carrying their body
weight or more and water and it's
just dirty. Any people, right.
Wow.
Yeah.
Most of the hunters we were given this
film area treatment fully a flareon a
worm is this crazy kind of,
it comes from black fly bites,
but it's from like contaminated water
that the flies goto and breed and they
come and they bite you and then you can
get, you can get river blindness from it.
Oh, it's river blindness. River
blindness is a disease that also,
there's a pygmy woman named Mama Mary Amo.
And uh,
I love her to death and she's so
great. Um, but she's lost five of her,
seven children due to this
illness and her husband. Um,
and there's, uh, there's
a video on it too,
and I think it's called the opportunity
at freedom or something that's on the
water foresight. But five or seven
children are gone and her husband,
and it's all waterborne disease
and she has river blindness. So,
not only has she lost all her, not all of
her children, but five and her husband,
but she's blind and she's blind
because of, of river blindness.
And so though the worms getting your
body and there's five different kinds of
malarial worms in one kind of the worms,
like the babies go to your retina I think,
and they like attack and
eat and live and sleep, um,
in the retina of your eyes until you have,
until you have no vision left.
And four of the five
don't, don't do that. Um,
but what it does is it irritates your
skin. Supposedly I've had it, um,
I've had to take the treatment.
Um, whenever I took the
pill, it made my body itch.
And that's how you know
if you had it or not, um,
as if your skin itches cause
and so knowing the parasites,
it's killing the worms, killing the
parasites. And so what I was like, man,
if I have this and if our team has it,
cause we treated our
well drillers first in,
some of them broke out in rashes and
hives and really were itching and she's a
part of it. If you go to that
region, you're going to get it. Um,
and if you're out there long enough,
maybe not if you go for a week,
but if you go for an extended
period of time, you're,
you need to at least take the treatment
to make sure you don't have that. Wow.
And so I was like, man, if I,
if I supposedly had it and if my
team has it, then I know the pygmies.
It's like ravaging them, you know? And
so we went to the different villages and,
and took a scale. And, and from that we
knew how much medicine we should give him.
I talked to this guy, doctor
Peter Hotez. He's, um, he's, uh,
an expert in tropical
diseases. Okay. And, uh,
he said that he blew me away.
He said that 100% of people that live
in tropical climates of parasites.
Oh yeah, I totally 100% believe
that that's, that's insane.
It's insane. You live there, you know,
it, uh, this environment that you're in,
that you're going and you're, you're,
you're, you're digging these wells, like,
describe to us if you could,
like, what is it like, I mean,
you're talking about intensely dense,
vetted vegetation.
What kind of like animal life and what
kind of wildlife is around you and bugs?
I have bugs. It's nuts. Um, yeah. My,
my wife's first camping trip ever
was in the Congo. Um, he took four.
You showed us photos of it.
It's hilarious. It's time
you were here. Yeah. Um,
so it was a big eye opening experience
for her, but the vegetation, it's nuts.
So the Amazon is the biggest
rain forest in the world,
but the Congo is the second largest.
But as it is,
the densest, the Ma, the thickest,
it's the hardest to navigate through.
Um, uh, there's parts in Uganda that
barely touched the stuff in Congo,
but they call it the impenetrable forest
because a, they're sayings that it's,
um, uh, I forget,
but it's harder for a fish to swim through
the or the rivers there because even
the rivers are thick vegetation and
all this stuff and um, and some parts.
But dude, it's, it's crazy like
walking through and hiking through.
I have a picture that's going to be in
my book of have been walking and I was
like, how much of this do we
have to walk through? It was,
we were literally machete using a machete
to get through to this pygmy village.
And I'm like, Dang. They walked through
this every day where it's like the,
you're just walking through the
thicket that's going across your face,
going across your arms.
There's bugs latching on to
you while you're doing that.
There's mosquitoes like crazy
at all times. There's the ants.
The ants will literally look like
a small creek or rushing river. Um,
I've seen on at least it literally,
at least two foot wide,
and you can hear them,
you can hear him.
It's two foot wide of ants and it's just
a black river because it's these ants
that are just rushing, running
in and out of things. Um,
and yeah, so it's, there's bumblebees
there that are like bright, uh,
like the, or they have a bright
blue or purple on their back.
I'm kind of partially
colorblind, but, but uh,
but I can see them and literally
threw the size of a golf ball.
They're like perfectly round.
They're perfectly round golf ball,
golf ball for a Bumblebee,
God for a Bumblebee,
100% like a golf ball.
And what we would do is Emily,
my wife brought a, a racket that had those
little, it's like a little taser for,
for bugs. Um, and it's in the shape
of a tennis racket and we just,
there's one village,
uh,
Andy Kwok claw and it's got tons of
those golf ball bumblebees and they're
vicious to the bud on those
things is just the looks wicked.
You don't want to get stung by it. And
whenever you do it, it leaves like this.
It looks like you got shot by
like buckshot and a little bitty,
a little bitty golf ball
size. WELP wow. Um, but yeah,
we just smack those things with
that little Taser racquet thing. Um,
it's gotta be one of the
wildest places on earth, right?
I mean next to the Amazon. It's probably
like right up there. Yeah. Yeah. It's,
it's nuts. There's a, you know what, maybe
maybe this would give you an idea. Um,
Jamie, me, we get those pictures.
Um, you can start with that.
What is this right here? I wanted to
bring you a gift, man. I'm from the Congo,
but uh, actually go behind those
pictures first and check out. Uh,
but if you leave him that aren't great,
but that CMG and I knew you would really
connect with this little dude. Um,
we should have a picture up of a,
do you have a, just the first one
and uh,
in San g here is from a,
we call it tuned and tuned
to it just means whole,
but we call it the hole in the forest.
And, um, he's a little dude. And,
and in that village they make those,
uh,
those little hand prints
or actually the cloth.
So the cloth is this like bark cloth
and it's like a traditional way that the
[inaudible] booty.
Pygmies like make stuff for artwork.
Does that cloth that he's holding,
he's made out of bark. Yes. Uh,
actually reach in there and you'll
see the, the actual cloth that says,
so this was kind of a
thank you, um, way that,
that they kind of gave me a few things
to remember him by and to say like,
tell your friends and people that
supported this. Like thank you. Um,
but seeing g is, he's probably 12, I
would say this is bark. Yeah. Spark.
Wow. Spark cloth. So it feels
kind of like a canvas and uh,
sorry on the plane and got a bent up. How
do they do this? What are they doing? Um,
I'm actually not sure that it's the,
it's the bark and they beat it down.
They like beat it down, pressurize
it or something and, and uh, uh,
or put a lot of pressure when they're
doing it. What kind of trees us do,
you know, I don't, I actually
don't know. There's so many trails,
like a flexible cardboard. Yeah. So,
and they, they'll do like their
own kind of paintings and stuff.
It's really like traditional and you
can like even Google a bark cloth and I
think it comes up with the pygmies.
That's awesome. Thanks very much.
That's amazing dude. That's his
hand print. Wow. And so time. Yeah.
He's probably 12. None of them
really know their, their age,
just because they don't really have a, a
calendar and don't keep up with it. And,
uh, don't have school or
anything. Like, no, I phones,
no hyphens, no hyphens, no. Uh,
whatever it is, Google, Google calendars.
Wow. But, uh, the next picture, um,
that's right there with Ya.
But, uh, it's their village.
And there you go. Uh, on my, uh, my right,
so if you're looking at the picture on
the left, that's, that's Lorinda. And uh,
he's my translator and our director
of implementation to his right.
The guy with the hat, uh, that
is, uh, Leo may doesn't dope.
He's awesome.
That's the chief chief Leo May and
he's such a great dude and he's the
grandfather seeing g two over
from me. The lady that uh, uh,
I have my arm around them and then yeah,
right there that she flew home,
his wife and they're basically the parents
of San sankeys right in front of me
squatting down.
I'm writing from my right leg and uh,
so they're raising him because his
parents passed away. Um, but uh,
what I want to show you about saying gee
is he has a passion that's common with
you and I got to be there
for two really cool things.
If you can go to the next picture and a,
that's the stack and near your thing too.
But here's the,
the village at night and that dude's
got a sweet little guitar thing he made.
He used the,
he used wire from a tire to make the
strings strings of the string instruments,
steel belted radial tire, like that
kind of shit. Yeah, I think so.
I mean it was like a old abandoned tire
and he just made this thing out of wood
guitar. He got the wire, like
stripped it out of the rough,
stripped it out of the rubber,
and made himself a stringed instrument.
But if you send these over my back,
and this is just us,
this is how we learn the most
about how we can help them.
When we sit around the campfire with them,
we've kind of made a goofy name for it,
but we call it campfire university
because that's where they,
that's where they take us to school.
Whenever we're sitting around, we,
that's where we can hear the truth
about how they're really treated. Um,
no one else is around like any of
their oppressors and stuff. Um,
they're able to just be
themselves. Sometimes we would
pretend to be asleep. Um,
so other people would leave,
but now this is on their own land
and they have like freedom to,
to just chill and relax. Wow. Um,
and then if you know the
next picture, but, uh,
I just alone. Okay. So he got
that picture also, but that's, uh,
one of the first antelope wild kind
of bushmeat that I got to eat. Um,
so they call it, they call everything
bushmeat. Yeah. Basically I've,
I've had monkey, which I realize I
probably shouldn't do that again.
It's probably not healthy,
right? Yeah. You can get a bull.
And so that's how the Bulla from monkey,
and I shouldn't laugh, but a, I
didn't know. I didn't know about, uh,
that's how you get a bullet and then all
of a sudden the bullet virus broke out
like literally a month or two after I
ate the monkey and all sudden like, oh,
Geez. Uh, so this, uh, antelope did
the shoot this with bow and Arrow? Yup.
They got that one with the bow
and arrow seeing Dee got his, uh,
in the next picture, uh, he got
his with a spear and this is, uh,
is Christ. This is his for what
they do is they chase it into a net.
So they string these
nets up, uh, through the,
through the trees and then the
men and the women sometimes too,
they go through with like leaves and
other things that make sounds and they
scare the antelope into their, their nets.
I've seen on how the string this out,
these nets can be, man, they can
be a football field in length.
And then they scare the antelope into
it and then they have to catch up to it
before it escapes. And, uh, they
spirit. So Sankey speared that.
That's your little
dude. Wow. And then, uh,
the next one's pretty cool just holding
the head so they probably could have
done ed too. Right. Eat the brains,
eat every part of the tongue, the eyes,
hey,
don't waste anything.
And that in that village was the first
time I saw him eating a turtle and like,
I'm not that turtles that strange to eat,
but they even eat the shell. Why? Um,
yeah, I know it sounds crazy. I saw him,
I'm like, doesn't that hurt? But uh,
they would,
they would cook it over the fire and
I guess it would weaken the shell. Um,
I think, uh, but it still sounded really
crunchy. So they're chewing on the shell.
The shell eat every part of it
and a lot the fuck man. Yeah, but,
but I mean for them though, it's if
that's the only food they got, you know,
I have no idea.
I saw a crocodile once eat a turtle
and I thought that that crocodile was
fucking crazy. But that's a
crocodile. They didn't think a human,
a turtle shell at least.
Yeah,
I've been out in Louisiana with
my grandpa official soup in the,
well the Cajun guy just came over cause
we kept catching turtles and he would uh,
he'd cut off the head cause he can't
really get your a hook pack and then he
would just open it up and see if they
had an exit them and right there without
cooking it, without really cleaning.
He just popped the eggs in his mouth.
I was like, this guy's crazy. So that
was in Louisiana. It was down in the bio.
But uh,
let me go to the next picture.
These people have a hard time finding
food or is this like fairly common to eat
all these different antelopes and
whatever. This is, what is this a cat?
This is Sanji second kill.
So is there for his first
kill and a second kill and a,
they were months apart
though. Um, this is,
I think they call it a
large spotted Janae and,
or I think I'm pronouncing it right.
It's a g e n,
e t and it looks like a cross between,
I dunno,
a mongoose and a baby leopard or
something like that. But I've been,
someone tried to sell me Okapi meat.
They were seeing that animal. It's a,
it's got the butt of a zebra.
It's got the body of antelope and the
head of a giraffe. I know it sounds crazy.
It's the only in the Congo and
that's what it looks like at least.
But it's in the Giraffa day family.
And so it's the only other
surviving animal in that family. Um,
it's actually with the eye. Oh, look
at that. Freaky fuck is fine. Yeah.
I have seen these things
before. They look fake. Yeah.
It looks like a mythical creature.
Like I'm in the draft family and uh,
someone's tried to sell me the meat of it.
It's an endangered species.
It wasn't a big, yeah, endangered species.
And I would have gotten in a lot of
trouble if I got caught doing that.
If you got caught, I'll even try to put
me in life in prison or something. Really?
Probably. Yeah. If you had the means,
but how would they know
where you got the meat from?
How it had to know that it
was an okapi a B. He just,
he was selling me the button. Oh, I see
what the people eat. Zebras too. Right.
Um, I believe so. That's gotta be
an gone insanely tough meat. Yeah.
So back to my original question,
is it difficult for these people to
find meat or is it like a really rich,
a lot harder than it used to be?
A lot harder because a lot of
the deforestation is happening.
And so I've literally been able
to look up, see the, uh, the sun,
see that the is clear, uh,
through the canvas and stuff.
And then it sounds like thunder.
Um,
and it's because they're
cutting down these huge trees.
And so that makes it really hard for the
pygmies to hunt because the animals are
skittish. They get scared,
they get frightened. They, the,
there are a lot tougher to get.
Wow. Um, so yeah, there's the,
that's when he came back and first
showed me this tiny little a cap thing.
And so how do they cook that? Um, they
skin it, they keep the meat or sorry,
they keep the skin to make a hat
or a little like trophy out of,
um,
and then that's the spirit got it with
that was a smaller one is grandpa has one
that he killed an elephant
with. Um, but yeah,
they put it over a tripod of sticks and
then they wrap the meat and leafs and
they kind of smoke it so that
it, it, it seems to last, I mean,
they smoke it and it lasts longer, so
dry it out. Yeah. That's, um, and then,
and then they'll,
they'll soak it again and like boil
it so that it kind of gets back.
It's not so dry at times.
Like, I mean, it is a fish too,
and other things. So it's a method
of preserving. It's sort of like, um,
the native Americans did that with
buffalo and they do that in Mexico too.
Um, they, uh, they,
they take the buffalo and they make
really thin slices and they dry it in the
sun and then they,
um,
they're rehydrated again and cook it.
And so kind of like with their situation
of them being the first citizens of
Congo,
that's the way we always use with them.
The terminology similar to the native
Americans and what we did here, um,
pushed them off their land,
took the land from him.
That's what happened to the pygmies.
And so that's kind of, it's similar to,
to something that I was thinking
is, hey, we could get these people,
these little kind of reservations.
We have 10 different plots of land.
All of them are 247 acres,
or eight of them are two are ones
like half a square kilometer.
So like one 20 and the other is
like close to 500 acres. Um, and so,
but that's their land. They'll pass
down. And what we want to do is,
on one of them, we started replanting
trees that are targeted for deforestation.
So one of our agriculturalists that
were interning, we gave them a goal.
It seems Dramani great dude.
Um,
we want them to replant a thousand
trees and we're like, hey,
you can feed the anyone that helps, you
know, the pygmies, give them breakfast,
lunch, dinner. Uh, and we'll
give them like a day's wage
and teach them how to, to,
to, to make money. Um, and
how to, you know, work for
the first time making money.
And so when he came back we were blown
away because he had replanted 3,500
trees,
3,500.
So that's also what we want to do
too is a preserve their culture.
They love the trees. They don't cut
down the big ones. So the market where,
where are these trees going to?
Cause this is an issue that going on the
Amazon as was like Mahogany hard that's
out there. We have big, heavy,
heavy hardwoods and they take a
long time to grow too, right? Yeah.
Yeah.
They take a long time
chopping down hundred and then
they're doing it on a daily
base trees that you could drive an 18
wheeler through. So that's why there's,
there's times that a tree falls and I'm
like, is it about terrain? Is it thunder?
Because it's, it's this huge, massive
old tree that's being cut down.
You could literally drive and look those,
the redwoods they have and yeah,
I would,
I would say they're not,
they're not as big as the redwoods
and some of them are that big, but,
but some aren't. I mean, some you
could drive a mini Cooper through,
but yeah, some are, some are massive
and they're just cutting them down. Um,
just a perspective that you must gain
from being in this insane environment.
It's got to be a really,
for a lack of a better word,
enriching experience. Yeah. I
mean, it's so good for the soul.
I would say just your
heart. You, you feel, um,
you feel like you're a part of
something greater than yourself,
something bigger than yourself.
And I would say that that's where a lot
of my struggles in life came from was
when I was so focused on something small,
which is myself,
I was like magnifying glass or putting
myself under microscope in my life.
And it's like whenever I took the focus
off of me and put it on others like it,
it gave me such a,
a greater sense of purpose in life of man,
I don't need to live for
myself. Um, like this problem.
Like what if I could be part of a little,
a little part,
the little link in the chain,
um, to help to, to beat in the,
in the problem and whatever small problems
anybody he has in comparison to the
issues that they have there.
It's,
it's one of the things that
happens to people when,
uh, takes place when there's any sort
of a crisis. Like after nine, 11,
one of the weirdest aspects of being in
New York was how friendly everybody was.
Like everybody Kinda had this new
found perspective. They had this new,
instead of dealing with the
stress and the, the, the,
the grind to the big city and the traffic
and all the nonsense and all the agro
behavior that people normally have.
It wasn't there.
It was like people were friendly
and they were nice and kind.
It's like they had put it in perspective
because of the attack and it's just,
it's a shame that human
beings are like that, that we,
we have to have something kind of crazy
happened to us for us to predict. Yeah.
To unite us and to appreciate,
right.
Yeah. And just say, I would say
there, it's almost like they are,
are like that the kind of what you're
saying about New York and not that the one
constantly like constantly like that
they're constantly appreciative for
anything that they get. Anything that
they get for that day. The, even,
even whenever they're working underneath
their slave masters and they're getting,
um,
a minnow for a full day's
Labor or two bananas, um,
for a family of four or five that are
literally working from sunup to sundown to
get two bananas to share.
Like there,
like whenever we talk to
them about it, yes. They'll,
they'll say, we need more. We,
this is slavery, this is a slave labor.
Like it's terrible. It's, you know,
but whenever they get that food at the
end of the day and like they're thankful
for it. Like, because they got to have it,
but the oppressors use that as a way to
keep them hungry so that they have to
come back the next day
and work similar story.
That's a story as old as
time, right? Yeah. Hey,
can we show that next picture in that?
Sorry, I'll, I'll try to bust this out.
So this I love this is saying, Geez,
grandmother, she's wearing bins,
bins on the right with a blue shirt.
He's our director and uh,
got Kula is behind them in the blue
shirt and right in front of them with the
sunglasses on his Mama Leo. What is
she wearing? Runner waste leaves.
Leaves. At least she'll Sushi tied
Wa uh, vines and leaves together.
Um, and yeah, whenever, if,
if cameras probably weren't out
like they would like it doesn't,
it's not a big deal like close or
not close or anything like that.
But whenever we bust out a
camera because it's like, hey,
this is going to be a cool celebration.
So why we bust out camera's
different than the show up.
Blow up and blow out so that we
have pictures. What's so cool?
One of the greatest gifts I've
ever given Mama Leo, me, uh,
is a picture of herself,
a picture of her and sang g a
picture of her and Leo, me. Um,
what we do is we print up these pictures,
we get them laminated and they've
never had a picture of himself.
And so we're able to go back and give
them these pictures and they'll always be
able to cherish and remember this
moment, do they have mirrors? There's a,
there might be a half
broken mirror that's like,
I mean very tiny, um,
like compact. Yeah. Right.
And it might be like crushed are broken
and they might have that for the whole
village. Wow. Um, so
it's, but some places, no,
some places not at all.
Some places I give them my iPhone and
they get to look at themselves and they're
just like, oh my goodness. Cause they've
only seen themselves really. And uh, and,
and reflection of water
and stuff like that.
And how long before they
start taking selfies?
The kissy face or, right, no, I've even,
I've even had the, uh, the duck face.
Um, there were duck lips, but, uh, I mean,
on my Instagram at the,
the big pig meat,
there's some pictures of me
actually given this village, uh, uh,
pictures and dude,
some of their expressions,
whenever they get to see a picture
of themselves for the first time,
it's like the craziest
looks in their eyes.
Seeing themselves on a piece of
paper would only on imagine calling.
Imagine seeing yourself in a photograph
for the first time. Yeah. Wow. But,
uh, another thing that we just completely
take for granted, right? Oh, there's a,
I also brought you something that,
uh, that's inside that bag. Um,
I know you're a hunter. You like, that's
why I get you those hunting pictures.
I also got you some like handmade
knives that are from there,
from the Congo.
How do they make these by hand?
They like hammer on them. And then,
uh, what do they get? The metal? Yeah,
I'll just feel like they're
like butter knives. Yeah.
It looks just like a American.
They made this. Yeah. How
actually Josh helped me come up with
a joke to try to, to cause a joke.
Yeah. That one's a joke because,
uh, but I tried to get a joke.
This is the real one. Rascal you, I was
like, dude, there's a copyright on this.
That one, that one looked too
prettiest from our hotel. Uh Oh wow.
But this one is the real deal.
Um, so they made it out of a nail.
Some of the,
the,
the people that we're working on like
doing deforestation and like cutting down
the trees and they'll,
they'll build themselves a ladders and
so they're able to take the old nails out
of these ladders and stuff, um,
and make themselves a knife.
And so that's actually handmade
from seeing keys. Uh, grandfather,
the chief chief Leo may cause his hands
so small that he can actually use that
or do they use it with like a few fingers?
He might use it with like three,
but yeah, his, I mean, the dude might
be four foot eight, four foot nine.
Um, the, the average height of the move
booty pygmy man is four foot seven. Um,
so yeah, their hands are smaller
and stuff like that. And so they,
I think this into a piece of wood
somehow grabbed the other one and I'm not
actually, they push it down on that
wood. That's, that's the original way.
You see how it's a a
nail. This is nuts. Yeah.
So,
wow.
So this nail flattens out to
be that why that's incredible.
Do what he found was the old a piece of,
so in Congo,
the Belgian Belgian Congo with
like King Leopold, the second, um,
who is due to as evil as Hitler,
um,
I mean they, they say during
his reign of Congo, he, he's,
he said in Europe that he
was like the savior of Congo,
that he was helping all the Congolese,
but really it was extorting them for,
for mainly rubber in ivory.
And there was an estimated
20 million people.
And there's a book called King Leopold's
ghost in the guy had a big old beard.
Kind of like, I have one of those
pictures with saying, Gee, um,
but uh,
but what,
what they say was that it's an
estimated 10 million people,
half the population of Congo,
that,
that he was responsible for
killing and murdering Jesus.
So they call that like the African
Holocaust or one of the first holocaust,
because there was, you
know, six some, I mean,
I'm not sure about the Jewish holocaust,
6 million or something like that. Um,
but this was eight to 10 million people.
Half the half of the Congo was,
was murdered and everything else just
over rubber, the rubber boom. And uh,
and ivory and I had, I had a slingshot
for you from like their original rubber,
uh, but it kind of like rotted and broke.
So anyways, the original rubber. Yeah.
It's like, it's, it's like white whenever
it first comes out and it's, it's, it's,
uh, they just made a slingshot. It
was seen Ge and so I brought it.
Yeah. They, they know like
birds and stuff and trees. Um,
so I've seen him eat in parrots and
African gray [inaudible] stats. Yeah.
Anything they can get me in.
Um, they'll, they'll knock a,
and it might sound bad to
our culture, whatever, but
this is their food, you know,
so, um, but they'll,
they'll shoot like a nest and a
whatever comes down, you know,
if it's baby birds or mama bird
or eggs or something like that,
that's free game.
So yeah,
I mean we are very privileged that we can
just go to a supermarket and buy food.
So we have these ideas of what
you should and shouldn't do,
but when you're starving to death, you
will eat whatever you can get ahold of.
And whenever the outsiders make it so
much even harder for you to hunt because
they're cutting down the trees and it's
making the animal skittish and scared
and so much harder for you to find them.
Yeah.
So there's no regulation whatsoever.
How many trees they can chop down?
Not at all. I would say. I mean,
this might not be a real stat,
but in my mind,
80 90% of the logging in
Congo has gotta be illegal.
They just go out there,
here's a big old tree,
let's cut it down because it's worth so
much money. And who was doing this? What,
what country up all over.
And they'll bring in trucks from
Kenya and Tanzania and Rwanda and um,
there's some like big businessmen that
then sell these hardwoods to China,
the u s the Brazil. I mean, just different
big countries that they send it out.
And I've seen these
hardwood, uh, on these roads,
sometimes three fourths of a serious three
fourths of an 18 wheeler or a lawyer.
Uh, Laurie is what we call them there. Um,
it can be completely sunk in mud or it
can just be fallen off of a face of a
cliff. Um, because it's so overloaded. Um,
they fill up these containers just
so full with this heavy, heavy,
heavy wood because if,
if they can get it back and then they're
going to make a ton of money off of it.
Um,
so they just overload it cause it's so
hard to get from point a to B to like
Mombasa and Kenyata where they can ship
out this stuff. It's just so depressing.
Sometimes when you think about the
damage that people are capable of and the
insensitivity that people can exhibit.
Yeah.
It's just that they're just go
there and just take all that wood,
chop it all down. Fuck all these
people over the, the, the whole,
just the fact that it's a small amount
of people that are doing it too,
but yet it affects an enormous amount of
people worldwide. Absolutely. Absolutely.
From, I think, I think they said, um,
I forget where I got as
a reputable source. Um,
but the size of Texas has been cut down
from the Congo rain forest in the last
like just 20 or 25 years last 2025
years of the rain forest in Congo,
the size of Texas, which that's
where I'm from. I mean that's huge.
It's 13 hours from east to west, maybe
more, uh, in Texas on good roads.
Um, so just to imagine like the size of,
of the impact that that's insane. He can,
it's nuts.
That's insane.
And then to think about the fact that it
takes hundreds of years replenished as
far as if they do get replenished because
the environment that they're growing
in,
it gets changed.
As soon as you chop everything down and
the sun bakes the land and then there's
less rain and stuff. Fuck man. Absolutely.
That's going to be such a strange place
to go while you're there and you're
trying to help and you're trying to
replenish and help these communities,
give them water and help them sustain
and then you're hearing these trees fall
and knowing that there's this,
these insensitive people just chopping
down trees left and right and fucking the
whole thing up. Yeah, it's nuts.
Like, uh, when, when my wife came,
we walked through a field that
had been just ravaged by the,
the illegal loggers and stuff and um,
she was blown away because these trees
were so much of fallen on their sides.
There was so much taller than I was. Um,
like it made me look like a dwarf by him,
just enormous trees.
And literally the first trip she came on,
which was only like
six months before that,
like all those trees were there,
all those trees were there and it was,
and now we walk into it and it's probably
like 10 or 20 acres of trees that were
just leveled in that amount of time.
And the way that they were doing it.
There wasn't by, these guys weren't using
the big chain saws and everything else.
They were just like going at it
with axes and stuff. And, uh,
a lot of it actually isn't just
for the, the hardwoods. Um,
I mean I would say that's
the majority of the problem.
But another big problem in,
in,
in Congo or sub Sahara Africa is the
charcoal everyone uses for cooking.
Um, they get it from these trees,
they cut them down, they throw, uh,
they chop them up into little
bits and then they, they throw a,
a big mounds of dirt over them and they
set them on fire and they smolder it for
two, three weeks I think. And then
it comes out and he's kind of hard,
compressed a little
charcoal pieces. And, um,
so then that's what they cook with
everywhere. And it's, uh, so that's,
that's another thing that,
that's a big issue.
God, you know, there
was a photograph of a,
a tree somewhere in California,
I forget where it was,
but one of the captions was this,
this tree is somewhere in the neighborhood
of five to 600 years old or something
like that. It was like, they were
talking about like when this tree,
what first came up,
Columbus was sailing. Wow.
And this is a tree that you could see
today. I can, there's trees that are,
I don't know what is the oldest tree?
I mean, how old are trainees? Not Been,
I'm not, I'm not even sure, but
there's a tree somewhere. Yeah. I mean,
in the Congo it's gotta be the oldest. I
mean, that's gotta be the oldest, right?
Yeah. Probably when are up there.
It's a, it's, it's crazy. And then,
and then there are times that the
trees, just the cycle of the forest, um,
these trees can fall over.
Um, but, uh, like we,
we took a family of five to the hospital.
Here's one right here with
Feisal Lauzen trees, 5,000 years.
Bristol cone pine tree from California
White Mountains is thought to be almost
5,000 years old.
Goodness.
The oldest non clonal tree in the world,
the exact location of that Donald twisted
Methuselah is a forest service secret
for its protection.
Wow. Wow. That's insane. That's crazy man.
I had no idea that could be 5,000 years
old and then some asshole can just come
along and just cut it down.
Make charcoal with it. Yeah.
And some something nuts like, uh, I,
I came in here and remember I had gotten
sick and I had to postpone on you.
Um, and anyways, we went
to a hospital down in, uh,
or up in Valencia I think.
And they had thrown me in a room for
three hours and they were thinking about
getting Hazmat suits
out and all this stuff.
Cause I thought you might've had Ebola
cause he came back from Africa. Right,
right, right after the Ebola
crisis. But it had been, um,
I had been back for like two months or
something or maybe even close to three.
And, uh, yeah, they were
going all crazy and stuff.
And this is just a stat that, that I like
to, it's something that grips my heart,
so that's why I want say it now, but, um,
me and I think I looked it up right
before he got in in here and it was around
11,000 people that a bullet took,
took out 11,000 people.
That's a ton. It's a ton.
It's a brutal crisis.
But I just remember the uproar that,
that and the fear,
like the outcry that that
happened publicly all over
the United States and only
a couple people got it here and
then, and still, that's terrible.
Um,
but whenever I compare that 11,000
people total in this Ebola crisis,
and then the stat for children,
and this is on water for his website
and stuff and on ours and dude,
it's what I want to fight and let people
know because there should be a real
public outcry and uproar.
That 5,000 kids,
5,000 kids under the
age of five years old,
die every single day,
every single day because of dirty water,
because of water borne disease,
because of waterborne illness.
That's a legit stat from like UNICEF
or one of those like legit places,
5,000, 5,000 a day. It's like,
it fluctuates from like 4,700
or something to 5,000 a day.
And like for me, man, I've,
I've, I've held two of those
children. You know, I've,
I've, I've dug the grave,
I've had blisters on my hands.
I've had a little dude named Andy
Bo's blood on my hands and like,
like Bro, it's, it, it wrecks me.
And like that's why I'm so
passionate about this thing. And like
I come back and I get it.
A bull is terrible and we need to knock
it out because it can take out so many
people. But why? Why are people not like,
why don't they have their eyes open?
Their ears open their heart
open to hearing about 5,000
kids dying every day up
into the funeral of five other kids.
I've seen the grave of nine
or 10 others besides that,
like in these are just among the pygmies.
I've been to the,
I've seen the funerals going on of
the, of their oppressors, like the,
the slave masters and the Mokpala
the non pygmies that surround them.
Their kids are dying of dirty
water and it's not, I don't,
I don't mean to go crazy, but no,
it's not crazy at all. It's that,
that statistic is crazy. 5,000 a day,
a day and they're under five years old.
So I mean, I don't know how many with
the six, seven, eight, nine year olds,
you know, I've been to the funerals
of those kids. We are very strange.
But what we have,
what we focused our attention on and the
Ebola thing is just something that was
over here because we were worried about
it coming over here and we're doing this
problem over here.
We were,
it's so convenient for people to not look
at impoverished third world countries,
people that are just, they've always
been in this sort of state of poverty,
so we just sort of accept
them at being like that.
We don't think that they necessarily,
that they have to live the way we live or
have access to clean water and medical.
We just don't even think
about it. We worry about Cecil
the lion. Yeah. You know,
this was the fun outrage about Cecil the
lion where everybody's going nuts and
freaking out. I mean, look,
poaching is terrible. It's awful.
So the animals are beautiful.
It's an, you know, I get it,
but the way we reacted to that,
to know your statistic,
to know that what you just said,
I had 5,000 little kids die every day
from dirty water and people aren't
freaking out about that. I think it's
like every 20 seconds. That's insane.
I think it's every 20 sites really
hard to swallow. Yeah. And Bro,
like wow,
that was,
that was my 5,000 is
tuts w w that's so crazy.
Just think about 5,000 dead bodies every
day and have them being little kids.
I wow. And, and, and the thing that
really wrecked me with that was,
so I spoke at this university in Oklahoma.
It's,
it's slipping my name or the name's
slipping me, but their students, um,
is right when I got back from Congo and
they had heard about what I was doing.
Um, I, he goes southern. Um,
it's an Oklahoma City as
Smu. And uh, and they,
they said, come, come speak
to our students. We want to,
we want to try to raise enough for
a waterwheel. And um, and dude,
they set out in their courtyard,
they set out in their courtyard 5,000
white flags and this is a massive
courtyard.
They sent out 5,000 little white flags
and on it said the stat that's 5,000 kids
every day die of dirty water.
And so I saw that right before I went
up and spoke and I went and solve the
courtyard and it just wrecked
me because like for me,
like the people that see that like
the stat can go in one year, it can,
it can jack with you for a little bit.
It can mess with your mind,
it can mess with your heart.
Um,
but it's so easy to go in one ear and
out the other at or once you sleep,
you know you're not going to wake up
thinking about that just from seeing those
white flags. And so like I grabbed
one of those white flags and I,
and hopefully some of the people just
from seeing those flags, we'll get it.
But like I had to write
Andy bow on the back and,
and then when I got up and
spoke, I showed him, I'm like,
hey everyone of these white
flags, you see it, you saw it.
Like it's a terrible statistic,
but this,
the real statistic is that each and
every one of those flags has a name.
Like it's a person, it's a
human being. It's a little kid.
And like he didn't have to die of
dirty water. Not In today's age nine.
Today's age,
when we have the answer to the problem,
when we know what we can do about
it and just people decide not to or,
or like you said, make the uproar
about Cecil the lion. I mean,
every American probably knows the name
Cecil the lion or at least 90% probably
do.
And like,
I bet not even 10% not even 5% no.
That 5,000 kids every day are
dying just because of 31 time.
Think it's 1% I didn't know it
was that many. That's nuts. Yeah.
It's just, it's hard to
internalize those numbers too.
Even if you hear that number, it goes in
your head and it sort of bounces around.
There's no, there's no point
of reference for me, man.
Like I absolutely 100% like,
so that was when I,
I gave the chief Andy Bo's chief,
my,
my first promise ever made the pygmies,
which was,
was we had buried him and he had told us
that he was rejected hospital treatment
twice. Um, so he didn't just die
of waterborne disease, but, um,
his, his other brother,
his father had died,
waterborne disease and his mom was all
alone now and she couldn't even cry Bro.
Whenever I, I met her, um, or one of her
eye, I saw her at this time, like she was,
she was, she was topless and I could
see every single bone in her sternum,
like every single rib attached to her
sternum because she was so hungry and she
was so malnourished and she was so
thirsty. And so our team went and we got,
we got mangos, passionfruit, um,
or mangoes and passion fruit juice,
a rice and Tilapia.
And we brought it back and fed it to her.
And it wasn't maybe 10 minutes.
And I was wondering if she in shock,
why should not crying?
I'm like,
why am I messed up from this so
much more than the mother? Um,
and it was because she
was so malnourished,
she just didn't have the energy to
produce a tear over her son's death.
So she got the mango, she drank the
passion fruit juice. It wasn't 10,
15 minutes later that thin,
she started sobbing because she had like
that sugar in that energy a little bit.
And then after that, like due the
next day, it was so brutal. And um,
I had blisters on my hand from digging
the grave and that's when the chief came
up and said, the first time we went and
got treatment, they told the mother,
you're too dirty to come in
here. Um, and she said, well,
can you give them treatment? I know it's
just a pill or a shot. And they said,
you have money. She said, I'm a slave. I
don't get paid the money. And they said,
well, then go away. And then, and then
the second day, the whole village,
and this is like 85 or a hundred people,
they,
they grab everything
they can, which was, uh,
like almost two dozen eggs.
They, they brought a chicken. Um,
they brought a bag of charcoal.
Um,
they brought firewood and then they
were able to beg because they don't make
money or these ones hadn't at this time.
And they,
they were able to beg enough for three
and a half dollars worth of Congolese
franc and $3 was the treatment.
$3 was,
were I think it was a dollar for the
pills that would have helped Andy Bo,
they're probably too late
for the pills to work,
but maybe $3 for the shot,
the injection that would help them
quicker. And it was something like $45.
Um, it's in the book.
I got the real number,
$45 for his casket that I buried
them in. And, and it's just like,
blew my mind that like the,
the oppressors, the people
that the Mokpala, the,
the non-Pygmies that surround
the pygmies were thinking like,
these people are so worthless
or, or they're like animals
or whatever, that it's,
it's easier for us to let them die or
cheaper for us to let them die than to
take care of them. And, um,
and so that's when the chief grabbed me
and pulled me the side and said, Faa,
which Fao? So, um, as my first pigmy
name, it means the man who loves us.
And, um, he pulled me aside and said,
FAA, like, we don't have a voice.
Nobody knows about our suffering.
Can you help tell people,
can you be a voice for us?
And that was when I said yes and no cause
I couldn't promise them clean water.
I couldn't promise them land.
I didn't know how all of
that stuff was going to go,
but I knew that through him in May and
through like some of the other stuff,
like a platform that hey,
I can,
I can at least help these people
have a voice of some sort.
Even if it's just with a hundred
people. Um, you know, maybe,
maybe I can help them have a voice.
Two boy, Justin,
sorry Broadway have you know, but
don't apologize at all. Thank you.
Thank you for thank you
for just being you, man.
But that what you've experienced and
what you're talking about is so removed
from almost everyone that lives here.
When we talk about poverty in America,
our poverty is almost ridiculous in
comparison to the poverty that they,
these people are experiencing, right?
What you're, where you're talking about.
It's just not even human.
I mean it's, it just, it's,
it's so outside of the realm of our
imagination to even imagine living in a
world where someone won't give someone a
$3 shot or whatever it costs to treat a
baby is dying.
And this woman can't even cry
because she doesn't have any food.
She doesn't have enough energy for tears.
I can't,
I can't imagine that world.
And you continue to go back there to
try to help these people and now you are
going to fight like not just,
not just like try to build them wells,
not just try to help them and
get them food. But now you are,
you're going to fight in Bellator and
try to raise more awareness for this.
What is it man?
You,
you make this decision. You decide to
come back to America, your training, uh,
in Dallas, right? You're training a team
to take down where Johnny Hendricks,
former welterweight champion trains big,
giant modern facility,
one of the best places in the world.
And you are preparing for this fight.
But your main goal,
you love the sport,
but your main goal is to try to
bring awareness to the pygmies. Yeah,
absolutely.
So it's kind of a crazy way of around
about sort of a way of getting attention
to them. They'll get to compete
in a sport and arguably the
most brutal sport in the world.
Yeah. Yeah. I think for me,
I always thought I could only do,
or for the last four years I'm
almost fight or flight. Yeah. Five.
I thought I could only
do one or the other. Um,
first and foremost, like the,
the my family and the people,
they're like, I'm not ever
going to give that up and like,
so it's worth it to me if I never had a
fight again, fine. So be it, you know,
like, uh, that's okay with me. Um,
so I was just so focused on that and
building the team and getting something
legitimately started that will
really impact them long term,
not just a flash in the pan. And, um,
but I saw fighting as something
that that is a platform.
I mean, I'm, um,
I'm here with you now just because I was
a fighter and then the other stuff that
came about,
but that's the link together.
And so my wife's or talking to me and
other people start talking to me and kind
of said, well, what if he could do both?
And yeah, fighting the lifespan of it,
that's kind of like a flash in the pan.
It's just, it's a short, limited window.
And um,
and the thing,
the problem there is going to take life,
lifetime worth of dedication.
And so what if,
what if we're a season in my life
for it could just be a year or two,
I'm planning on it being
five to seven years.
That way it can really make a run if
I can. Um, that's what I want to do.
Um,
and what if that can set,
set it up in a way that,
that the longterm solution and
impact is bigger, better, greater,
more sustainable. People
know about it more. Um,
and people want to get involved.
Like I think that it's hard kind of
living in the two different worlds going
back and forth. Um, because
they're so different. Um, I
kind of feel like I don't,
like, I go there and I see what's
wrong and I'm like, oh, that's not,
it shouldn't be like this, but I
come back here and I'm like, Huh,
what's wrong here?
And it shouldn't be like this.
And so I feel like I kind
of don't necessarily belong
in either one. And if I do,
I belong more in the forest
with them because our, our,
our hearts are so connected.
And so it's like culture shock here.
And I don't get culture shock
there at all. Um, I love it.
But what if you get culture shock when you
come back to America? Yeah, absolutely.
Man. Absolutely. From being in the Congo,
the culture here messes with me.
Kardashians. That kind. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. That, and uh,
and I went to Popeye's right when I got
back and it was after I had buried Andy
bow and it was my second trip back coming
back and it was in like 2011, I think,
or maybe 2012.
And I get back and I'm in a,
I go straight to Popeye's and it's in
Atlanta and I walk inside and there's this
mom and daughter and they're there with
a group that's going to do like some
kind of international aid in Haiti,
Haiti shirts on and it wasn't too
long after the earthquake and stuff,
maybe like year and a half,
two years after.
And the daughter is sitting
there and she's saying, uh,
I'm going to get a coke and I'm waiting
behind them at the the coke machine.
And so she starts filling up with
coke. Her mom goes, pour that out.
You're not going to have that. And she
goes, mom, they don't have coke in Haiti,
which coax Congo coke's everywhere.
That was the first thing I wanted to say.
Like, Hey, there's door you guys.
There's coke there. Um, but,
but right after that, like the mom's
like, if you drink that you're grounded.
She goes, mom, you're going
to ground me over coke.
And then they just went back and forth
bickering and then all of a sudden turned
into, you are grounded two
weeks when we get back.
Then all of a sudden the girl got
pissed, looked at her mom and said, mom,
I hate you.
And she stormed out and this is at
the airport. They got their shirts on.
They haven't even gone on the trip yet.
And I'm just thinking like I
wanted to grab, I'm not a mean way,
but grab them and just say look,
love each other like you find over coke,
you're fine over sugar water.
Like stop like stop it.
Like love each other like you're about
to get a rude awakening when you go to
Haiti.
And I've been there and I've seen the
people walking through snow drifts of
garbage to take a bath and walking back
out and having to climb up that snow
drift of garbage to get out
after they took their bath.
And I've seen him digging
in the trash to find food.
I've seen kids sniffing
glue to fall asleep.
Like I'm like you guys
are about to get wrecked.
And like it wrecked me too cause I'm
like I just buried a kid over dirty water
and now you guys are fighting
over sugar water. And so like,
and I'm not like,
this is one thing,
I don't want to offend people in a way
of like saying our culture is terrible or
bad,
but I want to point out certain things
that like life's bigger than our small
problems. And if we can get our eyes
off of those small problems and get,
get her eyes onto the big picture,
like he'll do a lot of good,
it'll change a lot of
things in our own own lives,
our own hearts and our own relationships.
I think with people it's,
it's just simply a matter of perspective.
And when we don't have real problems,
small problems become real problems.
Like this coke thing for this little girl.
I mean it's probably, you know, it's,
it's just a natural thing that human
beings do and some sort of a weird way.
We just lacked perspective if it's
not right in front of our face. Yeah.
God, that's so crazy. Yeah. So I went
into a long story there, but uh, no,
it's a great story and I can imagine
that means that would cause culture shock
for you. You, you must be just like
so baffled by it all. And I went,
I went to one thing,
water four has been an organization that
is like believed in us since the very
beginning. Kind of like you. Um,
whenever I'd come back and had seen,
you know,
the two things but done anything yet,
I hadn't like gotten land to
start a water. I didn't know,
I just had the passion and the dream
and you put me on here and let me tell
people that water for Kinda
did the same thing. And um, uh,
they, they gave me the tools when I hadn't
done the training and knowledge when I
didn't know anything
and just got behind me.
But I got back in three days
later I was at their gala and um,
and uh,
and it was awesome.
It was a great event and me and I was
crying cause they did a video of me and
the Congo and um, then I had to get
up and speak and it was real tough.
But I, I, I go right from
there in three days later,
I met kind of like a black tie event.
Um,
and women are wearing fur
and all this stuff and uh,
and so it was just was like,
Whoa, from one world to the other.
But I see it as a way to,
um, like there they do,
they did so much that
night for this project,
for the people,
for their families,
with their furs and their
Tuxedos. Wow. But yeah,
the honestly though they were people
with hearts in the right place.
And I get it. It's just cultures are
different. We live different. We,
and so I don't want people
run around here and you know,
leafs and stuff like that.
I don't want them sleeping on the ground.
You don't want anybody doing
yeah, no, no, not at all. But uh,
but it's been cool me and like the,
the water for thing latte for you,
like fight for the forgotten has gone
into a dormant stage and our nonprofit and
we have officially partnered with water
four, we joined forces with them. Um,
because when it comes to like
the reporting the business,
I think it was even the
logistics and the training, uh,
their water engineers are hydrologists
that different kinds of things that they
can add to us are so great. Um, they've,
they've given us a truck, all
the tools, all the training.
They've really been a huge
like component behind us.
But one of the things I love
most about them is, uh, is yeah,
we're partnering in a way that,
that, how would I explain it?
We see eye to eye on something
like the owner. I mean the founder,
he says, water four isn't about
charity. It's about opportunity.
And like, dude, I love that
because when you just do charity,
like you just help as for
such a short amount of time.
But the waterfall method is like,
hey,
we're going to put the tools in
their hands that are the, the,
the knowledge in their heads.
Um,
and then we're going to look to create
an opportunity for them that goes beyond
what we can do from the West
or from our short term mission,
humanitarian trip.
Um,
we want to give this
thing a life of its own,
that it becomes a breathing, living
thing. We're even a business, you know,
like there's there in 31
different countries in there.
They're helping these
entrepreneurs do social good.
Like they get paid to
drill water wells and,
and to train nationals and the
jobs don't have to go outside.
They can stay inside the
house. And so I've just, I've,
I've loved that about him in,
and the cool thing that I love is that
it's not about us being the heroes.
It's about, it's about the,
the locals being the heroes.
Like I, that's the thing.
I don't want to be the hero
of this. I want to be, uh,
a spark plug, if that makes sense in
the engine. I want to get it started,
get it running.
But the people are the strength,
that engine, the thing that makes it
run a spark plug gets it started. But,
but the locals and investing in them,
telling them you can do it
fly on your own wings like a,
you just need the training. You just need
the knowledge. You just need the tools.
Once you have that, you're golden,
you know, do this for yourself.
Once they have fresh water though,
there's still going to be the issue
of food though, right? I mean,
it seems like with the logging, you're
saying that it's more difficult to hunt.
Yeah. So what, what
we've been doing is, uh,
we're interning the three agriculturalist
right now and we're about to hire him.
It's awesome. I'm so pumped. Um, put
the guy that did the 3,500 trees,
uh,
he's great at farming.
And so in three of the villages we wanted
to kind of start it on a smaller scale
first. Um, because it is
land, water and food, and we,
there's kind of a process to it.
You know,
you can't start growing food or
having a water without the land.
And then first you need,
I mean,
you can't live without water for
more than three days, I think. Right.
Or at least some of it. And, uh,
then food he can live for like
three weeks without, um, and so,
or something like that. And, uh,
so with the food we started
in three different areas, um,
three different villages once tuned to,
and they're the ones sankeys
grandfather Leon May.
He's one of the most
brilliant men I've ever met.
Like maybe he's never gone
to school, maybe, but,
but I promise like the dude is just a
problem solver and he inspires his people
to get her like the whole village to
get around the vision and let's do this.
And so we basically said,
start with what you have.
That's kind of the waterfall method
to, um, start with what you have.
And we're going to come and we're
going to, we're going to fuel it.
We want to empower you to be able
to do it for yourself. Um, and,
and that's all people need. They need
to look a little jumpstart. And so, uh,
so anyways,
in this village and just Liam Hayes,
I wish I would have brought in
the list of what it is. But, uh,
from the time I came back and got married
and went back about 10 weeks ago, um,
uh, I got to celebrate the 20th water.
Well, that was Doug and drilled.
Um,
and it was such an awesome celebration.
But one of the most exciting things
to me was that I walk into tune to,
and at first I was like, like
no way. How is this happening?
Like all of a sudden I was walking
through a forest of, of, of bananas,
like, uh, and, and, and they had
planted on their own. We had helped to,
um, we, we help when we can and
we want to help so much more.
But they had planted over
250 banana trees out there,
over 250 surrounding their village.
They had done a corn hole hole filled,
huge field of corn,
cassava, which is kind of like a, a
spinach type tastes, kind of like spinach.
They make SOM bay out of it.
Um, they had done potatoes,
sweet potatoes, peanuts, a
mere Cujo or a passion fruit.
Um, and yams, that's eight.
I think the list might have nine or 10,
but uh, but they had done that all from,
hey, if we get you your own land, do
you think we could help you with water?
And you could help us with the labor.
Some of it like taking the
tools inside the village.
Like they love that they come
and help us. Then it's like, hey,
we want to get a farming project started.
Can we empower you to do that?
We gave them some tools,
we gave them some seeds,
we gave them some banana trees and
they just ran with it, man. And so, um,
I dunno,
I just,
I just love seeing that if you empower
someone instead of treat them like a
charity case,
if you give them an opportunity instead
of saying you can't do this for yourself,
get out of the way, I'll
do it for you. Well,
it's definitely a much more intelligent
approach and it's definitely better for
them and the future for now. Uh, it
gives them that feeling of empowerment,
the feeling that they're,
they're improving and that their life is
getting better because of their efforts,
almost dignity.
It gives them something to be proud of
instead of something to be sad about.
Like, oh, I can't do this for
myself. Oh, I can do it. You know,
that's got to be cool for you
to say, Yo Dude, I love it.
And one of the other villages, um,
that we call it [inaudible]. Uh,
and it's, uh, anyways, it was,
I at first my heart sank because
they really love their, uh,
in nine of the 10 villages,
they really love their huts. Uh,
it's very culturally important to
them, the twigs and leaves. Um,
but whenever I walk in on onto their land,
all of a sudden I saw huts that
were just like the Mokpala,
just like the non pygmies. It was
the mud huts that were, I don't know,
four to six inches thick walls.
They had the leafed roofs. Um, but,
but there were much stronger houses
and all of a sudden I'd, I'd come back,
I'd gone back and then all
of a sudden to that village,
what was important to them? The
other one, the farming and yes,
this village also Melendez started
farming for themselves as well,
corn and beans.
But they started doing the huts
because they were like, hey,
if we're really equal now
we're equal to our neighbors,
then we can live in the same
kind of houses that they have.
We can stay out of the rain better. We
can keep our kids warmer at night. Um,
and so to them,
what was a value to them was one of
the reasons they get called animals.
Um, and, and,
and subhuman and other things is
because of their twigging leaflets.
And their neighbors will say
they live just like animals.
They live in a nest or a, we're
different. Things like that.
Well now this displaces a,
now they have houses just like
the others were equals now,
like that's kind of their, their
motto, like we're equals now. And uh,
so that blew me away.
At first my heart sunk.
Then all of a sudden they
told me they're proud.
They walked me into every single digit.
Why'd you heart sank? Because I thought,
I thought they maybe had had
gotten pushed off their land. Uh,
the muck Paula had taken the land back
in and we have strict agreements and
paperwork and like stamped in the
courts and law, uh, that, that hey,
this is the agreement that is going to
be a peaceful way of doing this and we're
going to help the community
come up together. So it'd be,
it'd be dumb of us to go in and say, we're
just gonna help the pygmies. So we, we,
we,
we helped the community altogether.
I thought these guys had gone back on
their word, but then all sudden it was,
whoa, they're living just
like everybody else. No.
These people have any idea
of the impact of your work.
Like did they understand like
that you could reach, I mean,
you're probably going to a million plus
people are going to hear this podcast,
the impact that you're going to have
when they talk about it on spike TV
probably just as much.
I mean,
I dunno what the number of
spikes been getting for fights,
but it's gotta be probably close
to a million or at least, yeah,
I think it's over it. There's a lot of
fucking people that are going to be,
did they understand that? Do they
have this idea of who you are? Um,
they know me as Fal sa
[inaudible] that's my name.
D till like, like to try
to interrupt you, but no,
you're fine to you or to me. Okay.
Like you tell me that 5,000 people,
5,000 children die every day
because of lack of water.
I can't get that in my hat. I mean,
I know I, I'm trying and uh, it's,
I know it's horrific, but I mean,
my head is like, what? Look this,
so it's almost like
there's no place for it.
It's like it's moving around in
my head it doesn't, there's no,
but you told me your grandfather
died. I'm like, fuck man,
dude lost his grandfather. You know what
I'm saying? Like it fits. It makes sense.
You tell me 5,000 kids die every day
because of a lack of water and I'm just
blank. It's like I'm trying
to find a place for it.
When you tell them that you are going to
fight on spike TV and they're going to
show a video of why you're doing this and
I'm going to show a profile on you and
they understand what you do. Do they, do,
they understand these people are gonna
see you. Did they ever see you fight?
If they seen a video of you, they've seen
a Topps card, a Topps card, that's it.
Tufts card.
Do they know what you do?
Do they know that you were on the ultimate
fighter? Do they know about the UFC?
They understand. My drilling team does
the, the well drilling team, right?
And sometimes we'd put on
little entertaining things, uh,
where the pygmies would come around.
And I'm not going to wrestle
one of those guys, but uh,
but I'll wrestle some of
our well drillers. There's
one guy that's at least six,
five on our team.
And so I'm,
I'm wrestling with them and throwing them
around a little bit. And I think, uh,
Ben will tell them sometimes that, you
know, hey, in the United States he was a,
he was a wrestler,
he was a fighter. And people know
who he is. But for them, the,
for a frame of reference,
kind of like you're saying,
you don't have the frame of reference
for 5,000 kids dying every day.
I don't think they really
have a reference for, um,
for professional sports television.
Like,
and I've never met a bootie pygmy that has
a cell phone, um, that has electricity.
Uh,
I've met someone with a flashlight or a
couple of guys with a flashlight that's
like the cool dude. Yeah,
absolutely. So, uh, and,
and we've,
we've left behind some of the cheaper
like radios and they can get like two
stations or one. Um, and uh,
but, but for them, like, I mean,
soccer, I don't even think they really
know that that's a professional sport.
Maybe they do,
but they don't have a reference because
they don't know any of the players.
They don't watch any of the games,
like they know kick a ball around.
And a lot of times it's just in
a big circle. Um, but there's,
I shouldn't not misspeak because
there's a couple places that, um,
with the Mokpala, they have like
some, some teams and have some, uh,
some fields and stuff. But that's only
like two of the places. Other than that,
it's just a circle and you
kicked the ball around. So no,
I wouldn't say that they,
they have a reference for what,
what I'm trying to do for them. But
like, that's not what it's about for me.
No, I know it's not about that for
you, but for them it's gotta be so odd.
This guy, the first white person they've
ever seen, and there's a video of you, uh,
that was going around reddit long time
ago of you meeting them and them touching
you. And I can't believe you're
white and they're freaking out.
But this guy who shows up out of nowhere,
like a mythical creature mean if you,
if, if, if
no one else could ever reach them, and
if, if you stopped going there, and if,
uh, if all contact with
the outside world ceased,
you would be like a part of their
religion. I mean, do you understand that?
You'd be like some Jesus Christ type
character that comes out of nowhere. Some,
some magical man from another world
who shows them how to get water,
loves them and cares for them.
Here's a video of you,
whether they're grabbing
you and touching you.
And that's a actually the Mokpala, uh,
that's the non pygmy kiddos. So their,
their parents, uh, most of them
were kind of the slave masters.
And even even from that village where
the reason Andy Bo was denied hospital
treatment. So, but,
but really like I believe this
was a moment used in my life,
especially how it blew up.
I just put it up for a couple
of my friends to look at
and it had like literally
40 views before all of a sudden it went
viral and it was up for like four months,
three months, four months. Um,
but now look at their beautiful
smiles now, right? Yeah. On,
on Youtube it's 1.8,
I think,
but on Facebook a bunch of people ripped
it and posted it and it was over 12
million. Um, so 12 million on Facebook.
You literally are like a
religious character. I mean,
I don't know about that.
I know you don't know about that cause
you're humble and you're not looking at
it like that.
But just the sheer
perspective like for them to,
to be living in that world.
Where are their number one concern
is feeding themselves parasites,
trying to get some clean water.
And some guy comes from a,
a place on the other side of the planet
and this guy does this thing called
mixed martial arts and he fights
and they broadcasted on television,
something they've never seen before in
their life. They've never seen a video.
They have no idea what MMA is. They
have no idea the impact. Right.
And then you're going on podcasts and
talking about it and you have websites to,
to help people contribute. I
mean, this is a to them, I mean,
I can't imagine that they would
understand what this is, is
wanting them rubbing your head. Yeah.
They're going crazy robbing your hair.
They're doing my bearded men
again. But uh, it's so funny too,
countries when you backed up, when you
look there all right. Back Up. Yeah.
He's standing up straight. Runaway. Right.
Like they didn't know what to do with.
Yeah. Well I've gone into some
villages before and literally they,
the women grabbed their
children and dive into the huts.
The men run and hide behind trees,
um,
and grabbed their bows and arrows
and spears and gone. And uh,
and it's funny cause in those cases
it's only happened a few times,
like three or four times. I'm actually
pretty much every new village,
so maybe 10 times. But uh,
but whenever I go in a,
it's funny cause it's normally the women
that are the brave ones that come up to
me first and then and then touch
my arm or touched my, my, yeah,
it just,
I've heard once before it was because uh,
yeah I'm the first white guy
they were seeing or is he real?
Cause we didn't give this village of a
heads up that we were coming or that how
was comparable. Snowman is on the
way. And one time they were like,
is that a lion man? Um, another one
was like a, is that, is that a spirit?
Is that like a ghost guy?
I'm telling you it and you're
like an alien I, yeah. Well,
and then look at me dude.
It's crazy wild looking guy here with all
this hair and then there I just let it
go wild.
And so it's so strange with the
pygmies and the Mokpala that's there.
Most of them even are well drilling team.
Uh,
everyone is fascinated with my body here,
the arm here because,
because they don't have arm here or like
here and then I'm just covered in it.
So they'd be going through some kind
of a white gorilla or something.
My buddies would call me like great
white Sasquatch or the vanilla gorilla.
That's so strange.
Just can't imagine how
odd it must be to them.
And they don't even
really know how odd it is.
Like for them to not have the
preference of television not understand,
like if you could take them,
give me,
I mean if spike TV wants
to really make an impact,
what the need to do is go to the,
take some of those
little fellows and fly them
out to your fight. Yeah.
That was the fucking nuts man with think.
What would they think that
a grocery store, I wonder
what they think us using it.
I always thought using a credit card
cause for that transaction transaction it
looks like they give it right back to you.
Yeah.
So it's like you get all this food,
you give the cashier, uh, the,
the card they smile at,
you give it back and then you need to
take all the food out. It's like food.
You think it's very here, right. Um,
trying to get them to understand what
the Internet is. Yeah. Or the moving,
moving sidewalks at the airport.
Uh,
how about fucking time square
in New York City or Vegas? Yeah,
sometimes I think about it and
I think it would be awesome.
Other times I think about it and I
think it would be torture. I don't know.
I mean maybe that sounds crazy,
but also like giving them a place where
all of a sudden they have everything at
their fingertips and take him into
a grocery store and then they, they,
they miss their family right away,
taking them out to go to a Benjamin
or Lorraine goes wedding. Uh,
they started missing the forest, like
deeply missing their friends and family,
deeply missing.
I've never seen it before.
Getting so homesick for something
in two or three days. Well,
I can only imagine this bond
because they're their struggles.
So it's so different than the stay alive.
And then when they were with us,
they had,
they had the food everywhere.
Like we're cooking the meals for him and
everything when they came to the town.
And I took a,
as names kept Tula and uh,
he's on the video that's on, on
Kickstarter launched today. But, um,
uh, he passed away recently
and a mess me up. But, um,
he's one of my favorite
dudes. And, um, anyways,
I took him to the hospital
like seven times. And um,
what is this, Jamie, what are you putting
up? This is the Kickstarter. And how do,
how does someone get to this?
Uh,
it's kickstarter.com and then it's
fighting for freedom. It's a new,
it's going to be a documentary. We want
to tell the story. I don't know if,
if we got five minutes. Yeah,
yeah, sure. Play it, play it.
We could do it with the
volume. Yeah. In my American
bubble. Can we, can we restart?
Yeah.
Okay.
There are two people groups in
the rain forest. The muck, Paula
meaning non pygmies and pick the pygmies
are the muck palace leaves Java or the
forests or exist. Now that was a draw
day. It's not just a thing of the past.
I mean that's what I thought. You
know, living in my American bubble,
you know there's no slaves today.
You got rid of that in the 18
hundreds slavery in today's age,
why
community's torn or four
different generations that
their cost monkeys or jungle
people tell us we are nothing
after that, their costs,
nothing. If he called me later,
yeah I create us or are
we human [inaudible] their
slave masters and come up to
me and say,
what are you doing with my animals or
what are you here doing with my property?
I own these people
work hard from morning until night and
we would get paid in two bananas to share
two bananas. They definitely need to
be given a few fish, a few bananas,
something small so that they can come
back and work the next day so that they're
hungry, not at the half to come
back and work the next day.
So I create us. We're human.
We have to fight this.
People are worth sightings.
My name is Justin wren,
13 years old.
I want to be a UFC fighter or
surf fighting professionally.
In 19 years old was on a reality TV show
called the ultimate fighter when I was
21 this main event at the hard rock in
Las Vegas when I was 23 and that was what
I always thought it was going to be.
My significance,
my purpose was the champion fighter.
If I could be that since then
have to come here to Congo.
Why should the sweet,
loving,
amazing people literally thought of and
believe to be animals whenever there are
these sweet, loving, amazing people.
So if there's something we can do,
if there's something I can do,
I'm going to do it.
I was fighting against people,
but really I was just supposed
to be fighting for repeal.
And even whenever we feel like the
last ounce of strength is leaving,
we still got to choose to fight and we'll,
we'll see something amazing happened.
I've seen people set free bro.
I've seen people set free.
My name is Derek Watson
and I'm a filmmaker.
And this story has
dramatically changed my life.
What inspires me about Justin is here's
a guy who's at the top of his game and
he leaves everything behind to go
and serve and love someone else.
So we really want to tell the story
through film because it's a story that
really can inspire an entire audience
to fight for something other than
themselves in a fight for freedom.
So what I love about Derek and I
choosing the crowdfunding route, uh,
and being on Kickstarter is that we get
to involve passionate people at to be
part of the store,
be part of the solution.
And that's why we're inviting you alone.
We could have gone different
routes for funding,
but we wanted to involve
people in this process.
This is an awesome opportunity to really
give my pygmy family of voice when that
was my first promise that I gave them
that I could try at least try it,
to give them a voice. And now I'm asking
you, help me, help me give them a voice.
So this Kickstarter campaign really
is trying to get just the hard costs,
the whole divorce,
his film to finish out things that you
have to do to get a film on the biggest
stage possible.
That's what we're asking you to do.
So this money is not going
to me as the filmmaker.
I am literally giving up all of my time
and the time of my production team for
free to do this because we really believe
in this story and we hope you do too.
And we're going to have some amazing
kickbacks were going to be talking to you
guys.
We want to make sure that you guys feel
as involved as we do as the filmmakers
and as Justin does as a subject in
going down this journey with us.
So you may be asking, why don't we just
give money to fight for the forgotten,
which is Justin wrens a organization that
he works with. The answer to that is,
yeah, that would be awesome. In fact, if
you feel like that's where you want to do,
um, and you want to give directly to
help a free pygmy slaves through water,
I would say go for it.
Absolutely.
Go to fight for the forgotten.com and
give their think of this though as an
opportunity to see just a
dramatic impact in the lives of,
of the pygmies and honestly in the end,
the lives of our audience as well.
So that's this project and
we hope you get behind us.
Yeah,
that's awesome. I just
tweeted that out. Oh Wow.
So if anybody wants to check that out,
go to my Twitter page and it'll
be up there right now. Today is,
what's Today's date? The
24th, Monday the 24th.
So it would be a,
if you're hearing this in the future,
just go back to Monday the 24th and look
from my Twitter page or go to fighting
for the forgotten.
Just do a Google start.
That's a Google a search
rather for Kickstarter fighting
for the forgotten. Yeah.
The Kickstarter is actually, uh, what
was it? Fighting for? Freedom. Fight. Oh,
did I say fighting for the
forgotten. Fighting for
freedom. Fighting for freedom.
But, but the book is fight
for the forgotten that
comes out on September 15th.
Um, there's a book with Loretta
that helped me write that. Yup.
New York Times bestselling author with
Randy wrote big John's book and she
helped me write this book in
the, it was cool. It was a,
it turned into something like a passion
project for her and that's going to be
one of the, the kickbacks
on the, um, the Kickstarter.
If you go support the Kickstarter,
you can get one of the books and
I'll sign it and stuff. And uh,
then if people just want to go on Amazon,
they can get the book.
And it's like half price right now
till till it actually releases.
It's like 12 bucks when it
released, there'll be like 24. And,
and the cool thing about that is 33% of
my portion of anything from the book,
a 33% goes to the, to the pygmies, goes
to water wells and stuff like that.
When you decided to get back to MMA to
try to bring awareness and try to bring
more attention to these people, how long
had it been since you were trained? Uh,
the entire time. Five years? Yeah.
Nothing. Yeah. Nothing. I mean,
I was hiking through the forest and I was,
I was no martial arts. Absolutely none.
What did it feel like to get back to
the gym the first day? Back to like,
I should have been
training? No, I, my, my,
my body had hurt for awhile and then
I only really started training, um,
two or three months before
I went this last time,
which was 10 weeks ago. And then I've
been treating this entire camp to,
um, well, uh, the last 10 weeks
or so. But it, it, it Kinda,
it was crazy.
They bumped me up on a card quicker.
And so from going to the Congo
to celebrate the 20th water,
well plus like visa issues,
they wanted to try to take it cause
a corrupt my five year visa. And um,
they were trying to take
it like how, how so? Yeah.
So when my wife and I left
Congo the last time, uh,
or basically they marked it
down, they wrote it down, uh,
that we left six months earlier than we
had no nine months earlier than we had.
And I have to go back at
least every 11 months, um,
to check in to show them like, Hey, I'm,
I'm actively coming into
Congo and doing stuff.
So all of a sudden my time with,
they said, literally, they,
I got a call and it was
from the university and from
our team, uh, the drillers.
And they said, uh, Faa, we heard that, um,
that you're going to lose your visa
in three weeks. I was like, what? Why?
And they're like,
go look at your passport.
Did they write down the
wrong or wrong date?
And so they literally wrote down
the wrong date of me, my exit visa,
just so that they could try to get
another $1,200 or $1,400 out of me for new
visa and um,
and I would have lost it.
And when I went in they
would have a way to say, oh,
you came in illegally and you lost your
passport and your visa and we're going
to arrest you and try to get
even more money out of me. Um,
and when I got my visa the first time,
literally I didn't have a passport
for over three months in the Congo.
I had to send my visa or my passport
to the Capitol and people I didn't even
know, never, I still have never met.
We're handling my passport. Fuck,
I'm in the forest and you
could have been stuck. The,
I could have been stuck 100% and I would
have had to do that again whenever I
got in back again. Stuck in Canada.
I did get him stuck in Congo.
I got a friend that was arrested in
Congo for nine days and was thrown in
basically like a dark dungeon
[inaudible] people for what?
He had a Gopro and they arrested him
for a Gopro. He said he was a spy,
um, said he was a spy,
threw him in the embassy.
How to get involved or eight duty
probably wouldn't want me to, uh,
I wish I could say what, what he
does. Jesus fucking Christ. Yeah.
Gopro gets you thrown in jail for nine
days and 90 days if you have helped to
get out.
Yeah.
And the thing that's crazy about Congo
prisons is you don't get fed. They,
you have to be fed by people on the
outside. So if you get arrested,
it's up to your family and friends
to feed you. And so this dude is,
he was all alone and he got
thrown in prison and then, uh,
you don't have clean water and all they
do bring your water, but it's dirty. Um,
and I think he was, I think
technically he was in prison in Goma,
which is a crazy city, like most of
the most insane places on planet earth.
A little rebel group
called the [inaudible].
Took it over and not too long ago
or like over over a year, maybe,
maybe closer to two years now,
but I'm rebel boot group came in the
military and police that were supposed to
protect Goma Gomez, a million
person, city, a million people.
At least that's like the,
the capital of the eastern Congo.
It's where been AFLAC is or yeah. Is, um,
or been f fleck or however you say
his name. Uh, he's there in Congo,
has a real heart for Congo. That's
where a Batman, Ben Affleck. Yeah. Yeah.
He's got an organization there and um,
just trying to do some stuff and Angelina
Jolie's it goes there and like helps
rape victims.
Um,
but when the rebel group came in,
the military and police that are supposed
to protect it, just ditch their guns,
ditched everything and ran
away and like, uh, I dunno,
a small portion just turned over to the
rebels and said they were already rebels.
Anyways,
the Congo military is basically comprised
of former rebel groups that disbanded
and came on with the
government. And so, uh,
there's like 38 different war warring
rebel groups in just the eastern Congo.
Uh, I think, I think, uh,
it was BBC in New York Times.
I'm not sure which one said w which,
but,
uh,
they call it the rape capital of the world
and hell on earth for a woman because
a stat had come out in like 2012
or 2011 that said, one woman,
every one minute is raped in the Congo.
She, it's a, it's a weapon of war.
It's 1200 women a day. And so, um, yeah,
it's nuts. It's crazy there. And um,
and so these guys in
jail there, yeah, he's,
he was in jail there
for at least six days.
And then I think they took
him to the capitol from there.
TheU s embassy had to get on. No for
released. No. So how's he getting at?
What is he doing for just
starving? I think so. I mean,
I would have to talk to the
guy about it. He, he, he,
him and I haven't really talked
about how all it was, it went down.
All I know is he works in surrounding
countries and the dude's awesome.
Like he's got a business that works in
a whole foods and other stuff that goes
to do social good. It's a really
great, I wish I could say,
I don't think you'd want me
to tell the story. Um, but
uh, so I won't say his name,
but he won't come back to Congo. I don't
think, or at least I've heard that from,
from people that surround them and
his family and stuff saying I can only
imagine. Yeah, absolutely.
It was for Gopro.
All he had was a Gopro and
they did that crazy thing.
Now I have the right people in place that,
um,
that they don't mess with
me as bad, although they do
have messed with me a lot.
Just like that visa, they just tried
to get money out of. Yeah, absolutely.
What a fun place Africa is. Yeah.
It sounds like a terrific spot.
Well Jesus Kinda, yeah.
Congos nuts. Matt. Uh,
so from time you,
you have five years off,
you start training again.
How long between that and your fight,
how long of a trained yes.
I think if I put it all together,
maybe four or five months solid.
No, no, that's going to split
up. Uh, uh, now I'm ready.
I can tell you that I'm ready
for the fight. Um, I think,
how long did it take before you
like felt fit again? I mean,
how long did you before you went back
to sparring and, yeah, I was the,
for the last four or
five months I've been,
I've been going to inspire you to help
Jared Rochelle, like get ready for, um,
a couple of fights and to help Josh
get ready for a couple of fights. Um,
and yeah, so I was in their
sparring with the guys and stuff.
But I'd say at first, man,
it was brutal. It was tough.
Like my body took a beating and,
uh, I was thinking I needed, um,
I was told I need a knee surgery,
I needed my meniscus cleaned up
and stuff like that. Not a big one,
but to get scoped. And so I was like,
ah, I don't know what I should do.
Should I buy it or should have
not. And um, and then I found some,
some great doctors that
decided to help me.
They actually called IPI there in Denver.
It's called an integrative performance
institute. It's a new place.
One of the doctors is the
ironman competitor. She's
awesome. It helps all the NFL,
MLB, NBA guys. But it's with a, we're
talking about it before, but Regina came.
Yeah, I'm a big fan. I treatment. So
great man. They started you, uh, you,
you start training and then like,
did you immediately book a
fight or how did you, uh,
how did you decide when you're
going to come back? I came into it.
So I flew out here three times,
I think for two weeks. And, uh,
was staying with Loretta
Hunt, um, working on the book.
And she said, what if, what if I could
get you a meeting with Scott Coker?
Um, would you want to just go
talk to them about exploring,
fighting again because she asked me
and said, kind of poked and prodded.
Are you going to fight again or
you're gonna fight again? And, uh,
and I'd already been thinking about it
and talked to my wife and which my wife's
never known me as a fighter. She thought
I did Tibo at first she didn't know.
She didn't know what MMA was. No,
when we first started dating and, uh,
when she found out she was a, Oh, okay.
Like I told her mixed martial arts and
so she's like Tibo or Kung Fu or do you
do like cardio kickboxing
with your friends?
But she's so sweet. She's so awesome. And
this will be your first fight to ever,
uh, well for me to ever be that she's been
at Josh's to UFC fights and Austin and
Dallas. Um, so this will be
your third life MMA fight.
And uh, he keeps saying, Josh,
Josh, Copeland's, Josh, Copa
Nine zero, the cuddly bear.
Everybody. Um, so when you
are planning on doing this,
you, you start thinking maybe I
should do it. Loretta prods, you,
you meet with Scott Coker.
What,
what made you decide to go with Bella
tour and not go back to the UFC?
I talked a week or my management,
everything talked with the UFC. Um,
I would say that man, that's a great
opportunity obviously. Um, I love the UFC.
It's great. Great, great. Um,
even you helping support the
water wells and Neymar cord.
I don't know if I said it last time.
Did I put a,
from one of his performance bonuses,
he gave us two water wells worth of
a donation. That's awesome, dude.
Nate the great and he's
seriously a great dude. Um,
and he might not have, I
don't know, he probably didn't
want public props, but, uh,
I'm giving it to him.
Uh,
and then whenever I came out and met
with Scott though, I just felt like,
you know, the UFC you could
get, you could get lost.
And I don't mean that
in a bad way, but, um,
there's 560 something dude's
under contract. Right. How
many of this belt around,
um, lesson than their,
their main card guys? Um,
I think it's significantly less. And then
also they, whenever I talked with Scott,
it was more of an idea of
we want to get behind this.
Before we even talked fighting, he had
sent out that video you just watched.
He had sent that out to
friends and family saying,
look what this guy from fighting is done.
And do they even have a champ?
Who's the heavyweight champ?
Uh, I'm gonna mess it up. Um,
it's a Russian guy. Uh, Volkov was,
and now it's a Vitaly or
something like that. I don't,
nobody knows though. I mean,
it's not going to be me
soon. That's what I'm saying.
I'm like, you could be developed
or a heavyweight champ.
That's like a legit possibility.
Right. And I would I,
this is what I like to look at it as
an me for my wrestling background in
fighting, sometimes you get,
you don't get this perspective,
but from a wrestling background, you think
of a podium and the champs at the top.
And then there's, you
know, the normally there,
there's a top eight are all
Americans or whatever. It's,
there's a podium of eight guys and
I look at it as me and I want to,
I want to get on that podium and
eventually I want to get to the top.
I want to get to the top of that podium,
be the guy at the top, the champ.
Because if I'm there, I have a bigger
voice, a bigger voice for my family. Um,
and so, I mean, people will look,
people will watch if I'm on the podium
and I guess they already are because of,
you know,
you and,
and great people that are getting behind
the story that see that it's important.
But I know that the
better I do in fighting,
the more people will listen.
And I know that's cheap
and shallow at times.
There's nothing cheaper or
shallow about that at all.
Did you live in like a movie?
You're living your life was like
this crazy inspirational movie.
This is amazing, Bro. You
know, it's amazing. I mean,
it's uh,
it's just,
it's hard to imagine that
someone could be that selfless.
It's doing as much as you're doing
it. So it's really, really inspiring.
Thank you ma'am. Me and whenever
I, whenever I look at it,
because of the team that we've lined up,
man,
the 17 full timers we got now about
to have 20 each and every one,
those people on that team,
like they are such fighters and they're
so giving and they're so selfless and
they'll go live in the fourth year round
and drill wells and teach farming and
teach all this other stuff.
So we've got a team of such great people
and we've had to let guys go that just
weren't,
weren't with it or are we went through
20 people before we finally got to our
team that we have now,
legitimately 20 people.
I can only imagine how many people,
the amount of dedication that you
have to have to live that life and to,
to be that selfless, to go over there
and dedicate all of your time and your,
you mean you don't get to go home. That's
your home now. Yup. And so it's, wow,
we tried to give them, um,
uh, anywhere from a month,
minimum to eight weeks
maximum in the forest.
And then they get to
come home for two weeks,
rest up a little bit and then
go back out. Um, wow. Dave,
south probe for parasites. Yeah. Get,
get healed up, get a other stuff.
So we're looking at ways how we can,
there's no like healthcare
system or insurance there.
So we're trying to figure out how we
can really set up our team that they're
giving so much of their bodies, you
know, like their health, their time. Uh,
they, they, they, we try to
feed them really well out there,
but still it's not as good as being
in a city or town. I can only imagine,
and I can only imagine what kind of
medical care they even have out there.
I mean,
that's why I almost died.
The four labs told me I didn't have
malaria until I was almost dead.
And then I got out until you're gone.
And they're like,
they either said 60 to 70 or 65 to
70% of my bloodstream was parasites.
And in Congo they didn't,
they couldn't see it at all.
So sometimes like, well,
like our head guy, um, we,
you know,
his wife was actually poisoned.
Like people can be just
wicked there and meme,
somebody tried to poison his wife and
kill her did, did poison it didn't,
it didn't kill her, but
a almost did, she was,
she was in a coma because
they were jealous. Literally.
Literally it was just jealousy.
They first tried to get, get, uh,
I'm not gonna say their names, but first
tried to get her her guy and then when,
after his wife, because they
knew that if they could get her,
than it would affect and hurt him.
And so we've,
we've sent her to Uganda for treatment
and Kenya for treatment and I think
they've come, maybe gone
through Tanzania, but um,
but it's been months and months.
Like she's,
she's partially has been
partially paralyzed on one
side of her body from it and,
uh, is learning going through
Rehab, everything else.
So there's lots of stuff with
health and so we want to,
we want to try to see how we can,
um,
loving her team that's given
so much, you know, like, hey,
whenever you guys got a health thing, let
us know and we want to take care of it.
So that's what's awesome. The backing
of water for their all in. And, uh,
honestly whenever I first got back I was
like, how am I going to do this thing?
How am I going to do it by myself? And,
uh, because that's how it's kind of been.
Um,
I mean I got a lot of support after being
on the show and lots of people were,
were behind it.
But when it comes to like the business
side of it and filing with us government
and all that other stuff, it was like,
man, I got a CPA, I got other people,
got my board, everything else. But I'm
like me. And all I want to do is go there,
be there with them, fanned the flames,
teach them stuff, love on them.
And then when I come back here, I need
to, to, to, to come on things like this,
speak about it. I need to train,
I need to fight, I need to win.
But I don't necessarily need to do all
the business side of things. So anyways,
waterfall has been awesome on
getting behind us in that route.
That's a beautiful,
that you've formed this incredible group
of people in this organization coming,
becoming a part of you or you
becoming a part of them right now.
You're Beltour fight
one is it? And uh, it's,
it's live on spike.
Take a bike.
It starts at a 8:00 PM.
Uh,
well it starts 9:00 PM central. What
day? Uh, August. 28th on Friday. Oh,
so it's next week. Is this
week? This week? This week
man. It's Friday night. Yeah.
Today's the 20. Yeah. Well
today's the 24th. Yeah. So
it's four days from now. Yeah.
Where are you finding it's in
Temecula. Oh, the Jenga. Okay.
So fine up a chain. It's 8:08 PM
central 9:00 PM Eastern. Wow. Yeah.
Me Know who you find a learning
Kurtz. Um, I'm fighting a Josh Burns.
Josh Burns is fight fought for Bella to,
or five times, I think, maybe, maybe six,
but I think this is a sixth fight and
billet door. Um, he's a, he's a tough guy.
He, he hits hard. He's a
finisher. Get finished guy. Um,
his records only I think
like eight and eight. Um,
so the kind of, I mean, he,
he goes out there and either crushes guys
or he gets crushed. So that's my plan.
Go in there and crush him.
Even though I hear he's a standup guy.
I've had so many people,
even as friends and messaging me saying
how great of a guy he is as a person,
and that is kind of hard for them
to root against them or, or things.
So it's cool. I'm going to fight a good
dude, but he's got to go down because
there's, there's, there's a
lot more riding on it for me.
There's so much more at stake now.
Wow. It never before. I'll listen man.
I'll be watching.
Thank you man.
Best of luck and give out all the
information so people can contribute.
Uh, W I gave out the Kickstarter
on Twitter. What else can they do?
How they, how can they contribute to
water for what else can I get to? Yeah.
If they, if they want to follow me on
social media, there's a, on Twitter,
I'm the big pygmy and on Instagram I'm the
big pig. Me, that's the my booty. Mongo.
Uh, it just means the big pig me. Um, so
that's what a lot of the people call me.
Um, that's where the nickname comes
from. Um, by the way that it's random,
but there's three kiddos
now in those three.
One of them is in tuned to that village
he's named is my booty Mongo Justin.
And so that's his full name is
the big pygmy Justin. Wow. And uh,
so that's kind of one of the
reasons why I'm like, you know what,
that should be my nickname, not
the viking anyways, but, um,
how they can contribute is me and fight
for the forgotten.org fight for the
forgotten.org. Uh, I think
later today or tomorrow,
also.com we'll be there right now it's
the old site on.com but the new improved
site is fight for the
forgotten.org. Um, the book,
I mean I think people can really,
I mean from our toxic is
the deepest people can, can,
can see into what I'm doing,
why I'm doing it and my heart behind
it so far. But on September 15th,
it's 28 chapters of, of this stuff. And I,
I go into a real deep, um, that's
on Amazon, Barnes and noble. Um,
well I'll tweet that out whenever
it comes out. I'll do it, then I'll,
I'll tweet whatever you
need, man. You are, you know,
you're an incredible person.
Thank you. Thank you, Bro.
You're, you're in credit.
And, um, I'm so thankful for this
platform. This platform is easy.
I'm just sitting in this
room and the valley,
how many people from
airplanes that I sit next to,
someone from San Diego that's watched
it and someone at the hotel and just all
over the place, man, or walk
around and people are like, oh,
that's just a room from the Joe
Rogan show. And I'm just like, what?
And they're like, oh,
what you're doing? So,
ma'am, I'm honored that I could have
you on and give you this platform.
But because what you're doing is just
a, it's, you're, you're amazing man.
It was just not a whole lot of people
like you, man. It's incredible. I mean,
what you've done is just, um, it's beyond
words. So, uh, anytime we need any help,
I'm here, dude. I love you man.
Love you too, brother. All right,
before I start crying, that's it,
folks. That's the end of this.
We'll be back tomorrow with Abby Martin.
Uh, the big pig, follow him, Twitter,
Instagram, all that good shit and a
route for him. Spike TV Friday night.
All right.
If Facebook fight for the forgotten.
Okay.